Hey, listener, and welcome to Smart List. Before we get into this incredible episode, I want just a moment of your time to set the stage a little bit. Sean and Jason and I went on a smart list tour last year where we recorded 10 episodes live in front of thousands of our biggest fans from Brooklyn to Los Angeles. And guess what? Right now there are more live episodes from our tour on Wondry Plus that you can listen to. You can listen to these episodes four weeks early and add free on Wondry Plus,
嘿，听众朋友，欢迎收听《SmartLess》。在进入这期精彩的节目之前，我只想占用大家一点时间来做个铺垫。去年，肖恩、杰森和我进行了一次“SmartLess”巡演，我们在布鲁克林到洛杉矶的数千名超级粉丝面前现场录制了10集节目。你猜怎么着？现在，Wondry Plus上还有更多我们在巡演中的现场节目供你收听。你可以在 Wondry Plus 上提前四周收听这些节目，并且无广告干扰，
after which you can hear them for free wherever you get your podcast. Find Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. All right. Welcome to SmartLess. Welcome, everyone. Please remember to turn off your cell phones. This is a reminder there is no photography or recording permitted. Now please enjoy the show. Go Sox!
之后你也可以在任何你获取播客的地方免费收听。在 Wondry App 或 Apple Podcasts 上寻找 Wondry Plus。好了。欢迎来到 SmartLess。欢迎大家。请记得关闭手机。在此提醒，现场严禁拍照或录音。现在，请享受演出吧。红袜队加油！
Oh man. Wow. What's the baby announcement? Yeah. Oh, they did the announcement. They did the announcement. Yeah. The guy already did the announcement. He told them to turn off their phones.
哦，天哪。哇。婴儿官宣是什么鬼？对啊。哦，他们官宣了。他们已经官宣了。对。那家伙已经宣布过了。他叫大家把手机关掉。
Oh, OK. Yeah. All right. Well, do you think everybody turned their phones off? Wait a second. Why are they applauding? Can they hear us? I guess we're also doing a brand new episode of smartless welcome to smart
哦，好吧。对。好吧。那么，你觉得大家都把手机关掉了吗？等一下。他们为什么在鼓掌？他们能听见我们说话吗？我想我们同时也在录制一期全新的 SmartLess 节目，欢迎来到 Smart...
Okay, good rehearsal. Let's go back. We should have done that before this show, I guess. We have a fourth member that we're announcing tonight. He's shy, he's got a loose bow, so he's gonna go. He's shy, he's very shy. We're so excited to be in Boston. Boston! What? And there are people up there too.
好吧，彩排得不错。我们倒回去。我想我们应该在演出前做这个的，我猜。我们今晚要宣布第四位成员。他很害羞，他有点拉伤，所以他要走了。他很害羞，他非常害羞。我们很高兴能来到波士顿。波士顿！什么？上面也有人耶。
I think so. Wow. This is really, really, really weird. You guys are so nice to come out and see us tonight. Thank you. I know, and the weather is so crappy out there. Thank you for raving the elements. Yeah.
我想是的。哇。这真的、真的、真的很诡异。大家今晚能来看我们，真是太好了。谢谢你们。我知道，外面天气那么糟糕。谢谢你们冒着恶劣天气赶来。对。
You know, we're really excited to be here. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, we turn the house lights. I want to see like just for a second just for a second Or do we not want to see all these people? We might get just a little bit. We just want to see everybody Hi everybody Yeah, so nice. Thank you for coming. Wow All right, let's sit yeah, let's sit let you for coming. So nice to see you. Wow. Oh, that's it. You wanna say it? Yeah, let's sit down.
你知道，我们真的很高兴能来到这里。对。对。对，我们把场内的灯光打开。我想看一眼，哪怕就看一眼，哪怕就一眼。还是说我们其实不想看这些人？我们可能就看一小会儿。我们只想看大家一眼。大家好。对，太好了。谢谢你们的到来。哇。好吧，我们坐下吧。对，我们坐下吧，谢谢你们的到来。很高兴见到你们。哇。哦，这就完了？你想说吗？对，我们坐下吧。
Let's sit down. Wow. This is really, no, no. We're going to switch. Oh, yeah, we're going to switch. We did a show. We did a show in these. We're so well rehearsed.
我们坐下吧。哇。这真的，不，不。我们要换一下。哦，对，我们要换一下。我们在这些椅子上排练过一场秀。我们排练得可真好。
Well, Jay, you just turned your chair. You got to leave it out a little bit. We've got to leave it out a little bit. Yeah. And sitting on a mic pack. All right, so this is where we, this is where Pasacold opened. Now we do, oh, this is just us, folks
好吧，杰伊，你刚刚把椅子转了。你得把它往外挪一点。我们得把它往外挪一点。对。而且还坐在麦克风包上。好吧，所以这就是我们，这就是帕萨科尔德（Pasacold）开场的地方。现在我们来，哦，这只是我们，各位——
shooting before the get- About our day. I'm new. I'm brand new. About our day, well, today, well, first of all, will always make fun of my emails. I just heard you mention it downstairs before he came out because he thinks I email too much.
出场前在瞎扯——关于我们的日常。我是新人。我绝对是个新人。关于我们的日常，嗯，今天，首先，威尔总是拿我的电子邮件开玩笑。我刚才在上台前在楼下就听到你提到了，因为他觉得我发邮件太多了。
I think I don't, because I'm always on emails. He's like, hey, cool it with the emails, because the, you know, came out because he thinks I email too much I think I don't because I'm always on emails He's like hey cool it with the emails cuz the light we did it's not about the you email too much is that you you you hat You feel a need to respond immediately and you don't think through your answer well It's true, and then you get in a lot of trouble. I do by the way good note good note I do I do get in a little bit of trouble But I like to respond quickly because I like when people respond quickly to me. Here's what I don't like. How difficult is it to proofread your text, your email, check your punctuation? Like if you send me something that's not well-spelt or well-punctuated, I don't feel
我觉得我没有，因为我总是在回邮件。他当时说：“嘿，邮件少发点，因为……”你知道的，他之所以在后台说是因为他觉得我发邮件太多了。我觉得我没有，因为我总是在回邮件。他说：“嘿，邮件少发点，因为……”其实我们做的——这倒不是说你发邮件太多，而是你觉得有必要立刻回复，而且你根本没有深思熟虑你的回答。这倒是真的，然后你就会惹上一大堆麻烦。我确实——顺便说一句，这意见提得好，意见提得好。我确实——我确实惹过一点小麻烦。但我喜欢快速回复，因为我喜欢别人能快点回复我。我不喜欢的是什么呢？校对你的短信、电子邮件、检查标点符号到底有多难？比如你发给我一些拼写不规范或标点符号不对的东西，我不会觉得
like you really mean it. You didn't really check through it. You feel disrespected. That's how I want to communicate my thought and now I hit send. If somebody doesn't do that, then I kind of half-read it. So you're saying that's what I do? I don't think I've ever gotten an email from you before. No, no, no. What are you talking about?
你是认真的。你根本没有仔细检查。你会觉得被冒犯了。这就是我想传达我的想法的方式，然后我按下了发送。如果别人不这么做，那我就会草草地读一遍。所以你是说这就是我的作风？我想我以前从没收到过你的邮件吧。不，不，不。你在说什么呢？
It's mostly text, but you're right. Sean's our adult. When we have to do what you said. When we have to do a three-headed email back to the people who are nice enough to fund something like this, he's the one that puts it together, and it's always very... Who answers first? Who do you think of everybody who answers first to every email that we get business-wise?
基本都是发短信，不过你说得对。肖恩才是我们当中的成年人。当我们不得不照你说的去做时——当我们必须向那些好心资助这样节目的人群发一封联合署名的电子邮件时，都是他把内容拼凑起来的，而且总是非常……谁先回复？在商务层面上，你觉得我们收到的所有邮件里，谁总是第一个回复的？
Sean. Sean. Yeah. I'm a tight second. But you hate that. I do hate that. I like taking a second. All right. By the way, that's so much more than a second. You don't even respond at all because Will is conflict averse and so he doesn't want to be a part of anything that can be slightly problematic. It's true. Well, first of all, I'm not conflict-averse.
肖恩。肖恩。对。我紧随其后。但你讨厌这一点。我确实讨厌。我喜欢慢一拍。好吧。顺便说一句，那可远远不止慢一拍。你根本就不回复，因为威尔害怕冲突，所以他不想参与任何可能稍微有点麻烦的事情。确实如此。好吧，首先，我并不害怕冲突。
I like conflict in the immediate, right? So I like interpersonal conflict, like when we're having a conversation, that I enjoy. I don't like real conflict that has to do with greater big world implications. No, sure. You know what I mean? He's the king of the people that go,
我喜欢当下的冲突，对吧？所以我喜欢人际冲突，比如我们在对话时那种，我很享受。我不喜欢那种牵涉到宏大世界影响的真正冲突。没错，当然。你知道我的意思吗？他就是那种人的代表，他们会说：
hey, sorry, just seeing this. You know, he's the king of, you know, the people that go, hey, sorry, just seeing this, you know. Just getting to this. That's so true. Thanks, everybody. I'm on board with all. Yeah. That's so true. And, you know, but, but, but, I said this to you earlier today, that sometimes I'll be falling asleep
“嘿，抱歉，刚看到。”你知道的，他就是那种人的代表，他们会说：“嘿，抱歉，刚看到。”你知道的。“刚看到这个。”太真实了。谢谢大家。我都赞同。对。太真实了。而且，你知道，但是，但是，但是，我今天早些时候对你讲过，有时我在晚上快要睡着的时候，
at night, and I'll start laughing so hard, because if something Jason Erwell said the previous, like, that day, right? And so, I'm like, I'm going to be like, I'm start laughing so hard because if something Jason or Will said, the previous, like, that day, right? And so- I did that day brushing my teeth. I spit all over the mirror from the idiot.
我会突然笑得前仰后合，因为我想起了杰森或威尔在前一天——比如那天——说过的话，对吧？所以，我会像这样——我会突然笑得前仰后合，因为我想起了杰森或威尔在前一天——比如那天——说过的话，对吧？所以——我那天刷牙的时候就这么干了。因为那个白痴的话，我把水喷得到处都是镜子。
But last night, Will made us all cry so hard because we were eating sushi and- Oh, he- And I kept saying- It's so dumb. It's so dumb. It's the greatest guy joke ever. And I kept saying I didn't so dumb. It's so dumb. It's the greatest guy joke ever. And I kept saying I didn't...
但昨晚，威尔把我们都逗得哭笑不得，因为我们在吃寿司——哦，他——我一直说——这太蠢了。这太蠢了。这是史上最棒的直男冷笑话。我一直说我没有——这太蠢了。这太蠢了。这是史上最棒的直男冷笑话。我一直说我没有……
I didn't have time to make dinner tonight. So I ordered Japanese sashimi. Not a great delivery. It's not a great delivery. What's that? Delivery for... You know, sushi and a dish. So shimi.
我今晚没时间做晚饭。所以我叫了日本刺身（sashimi）。（笑话）包袱抖得不太好。包袱抖得不太好。什么？外卖……你知道的，寿司和一个盘子（dish）。所以叫刺身（sashimi）。
By the way, and know that we're laughing, not only because the punch is kind of dumb, but it's so stupid. It's so stupid. It's so stupid. It's so dumb. You know what? You're gonna find a better delivery somewhere in this interview with your guest. You just work it back in, and they'll see.
顺便说一句，大家要知道我们在笑，不仅是因为这个包袱有点蠢，而是它太蠢了。太蠢了。太蠢了。太蠢了。你知道吗？你会在这次采访的某个地方为你的嘉宾找到一个更好的包袱。你只要把它重新揉进去，他们就会看到的。
I imagine that our guest is gonna try to work it in because our guests can sometimes they like it. I just provide a segue. Yeah, you do. You guys ready for the guest? Oh, yeah. Our guest really likes to work in sweaty bits.
我想象我们的嘉宾会试着把它揉进去，因为我们的嘉宾有时他们很喜欢这样。我只是起个承上启下的作用。对，你确实如此。你们准备好迎接嘉宾了吗？哦，对。我们的嘉宾非常喜欢加入一些油腻的桥段。
Let me just say that. Oh, whoa. Yeah. Like, and sweaty bits of clothes. No, no, no, no, I don't mean like specialists. I don't mean like, their meats and cheeses are sweaty. I mean, that they like to do bits, and that they, that sometimes the bits get pretty sweaty.
我只能这么说。哦，哇。对。比如，衣服里油腻的桥段。不，不，不，不，我不是指什么专家。我不是指他们的肉和奶酪很油腻。我的意思是，他们喜欢演小品，而且有时这些小品会变得非常油腻。
This is somebody that we know quite well. This is somebody, and when I say we, I mean that we all know quite well. Is this person specific to Boston? This person is specific to Boston in that this person is from Boston. Is it a sports person? Is it a male or female?
这是我们非常熟悉的一个人。这是一个——当我使用“我们”时，我的意思是，我们所有人都是非常熟悉的。这个人是波士顿本地人吗？这个人之所以和波士顿有关，是因为这个人来自波士顿。是个运动员吗？是个男的还是女的？
This person is a not a sports person. Are you unsure on the gender? I'll let you decide. By the way, the world just kind of, my question is just opened a little more now that it's not a sports person. Now that I don't love sports, I just don't know a lot of them.
这个人不是个运动员。你对性别不确定吗？我让你自己决定。顺便说一句，这个世界——我的问题刚刚范围稍微变大了一点，因为他不是个运动员。既然我不太喜欢体育，我只是对体育圈了解不多。
But, well, hang on a second. Just, but we'll get back to this. You, I know your whole thing, you don't like sports. But recently, you've started to enjoy football. Oh my god, I love football. There we go. Yeah. That's a great sound bite.
但是，好吧，等一下。只是，不过我们会回到这个话题。你，我知道你的那一套，你不喜欢体育。但最近，你开始喜欢看橄榄球了。哦，天哪，我爱死橄榄球了。这就对了。对。这段采访剪辑太棒了。
But, yeah. I, I, I watch it. There we go. Yeah. I watch it. That's a great sound bite. Yeah. I watch it, and I'm like blown away by the science of the guy throwing the ball and timing it, and the guy catching it, it's like, who can do that? It's not called science. I mean, who can do that? Lots of people can do that. I know.
不过，对。我，我，我看它。这就对了。对。我看它，而且我对那家伙扔球的科学原理、对时间的精准把控惊叹不已，还有那个接球的人，就好像，谁能做到这一点？这不叫科学。我是说，谁能做到这一点？很多人都能做到。我知道。
But not like, like, who is the guy I was watching in the game? Oh, the Rams. The guy from the Rams. He's amazing. Matt Stafford. Matt Stafford. Yeah. Do you know, hang on, check this out.
但不是像——我在比赛里看的那个人是谁？哦，公羊队。公羊队的那家伙。他太棒了。马修·斯塔福德（Matt Stafford）。马修·斯塔福德。对。你知道吗，等一下，听着。
Do you know the really famous quarterback that played for the Patriots? Okay, well, now you're making me like, no, no, no. Do you have this? Watch this. Well, clue. Wait a minute, who is it again?
你知道那个为爱国者队效力过的超级著名的红四分卫吗？好吧，现在你让我觉得——不，不，不。你有这个吗？看这个。线索。等一下，到底是谁？
No, no, I'm asking you to get that. No, no, no, no, no, what, but he used to play for the Patriots for the bulk of his career. And then he just finished up his career in Tampa Bay. Oh, boy. Oh, boy. Give me the first name, Tom.
不，不，我是让你猜那个。不，不，不，不，什么，但他职业生涯的大部分时间都在爱国者队效力。然后他刚刚在坦帕湾结束了他的职业生涯。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。告诉我名字，汤姆。
Brady. Whoo. Oh. Oh, what? Is that our guest? Is that our guest? It's not Tom Brady. Well, it can't be.
布雷迪。呜——哦。哦，什么？那是我们的嘉宾吗？那是我们的嘉宾吗？不可能是汤姆·布雷迪。
He retired. Our guest is like the opposite of Tom Brady. Wait, who would the opposite of Tom Brady? Our guest is just, is from Boston is so angry that they can't be Tom Brady. This person is, this person is a clown. A clown? This person is, clown. A clown? This person has lived in many cities after Boston.
他退役了。我们的嘉宾简直就是汤姆·布雷迪的反义词。等等，谁会是汤姆·布雷迪的反义词？我们的嘉宾简直是——来自波士顿，气得要死，因为他们无法成为汤姆·布雷迪。这个人是，这个人是个小丑。一个小丑？这个人是，一个小丑。一个小丑？这个人离开波士顿后在许多城市生活过。
This person lived in Chicago. This person was roommate with Bob Odin Kirk and worked with Bob Odin Kirk very closely. Is this cross? This person worked in California, wrote on the Simpsons, right on Saturday night,ons, Rotterdam, Saturday, at my going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I'm please, please, please, please. I gotta tell you, you know, we did a show last night,
这个人曾在芝加哥生活过。这个人曾与鲍勃·奥登科克（Bob Odenkirk）合租，并与鲍勃·奥登科克有过非常紧密的合作。这是柯南吗？这个人曾在加州工作过，为《辛普森一家》撰过稿，为《周六夜现场》……等等，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说官宣吧，拜托，拜托，拜托，拜托。我得告诉你，你知道，我们昨晚演了一场，
and it was Will's guest then, too. He brought on Will Fairline, thought he couldn't top that. Yeah. And he didn't. You notice it, right? What kind of show business are you running where you tellboston crowd? It may be, Tom Brady. LAUGHTER
那也是威尔的嘉宾。他请来了威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell），本以为无法超越那个了。对。结果确实没有。你注意到了，对吧？你到底在搞什么鬼的娱乐圈运作，居然对波士顿的观众说：可能是汤姆·布雷迪。（笑声）
And I'm backstage, and my dick goes up inside my body. Even further? Further. Further, they did already once. I'm backstage, and they you're like, yes! The greatest busted sports hero of all time. You guys are like, no. Not him.
我在后台，我的小弟弟吓得缩进肚子里去了。还要更深？更深。更深，他们已经这么干过一次了。我在后台，而你们却在喊：耶！史上最拉胯的体育英雄。而你们却说：不。不是他。
Kind of the opposite. I didn't say kind of. You know what? I did not say kind of, but I said, shitty show business is this. But you're unbelievable. You excel in the sport of comedy. Yeah. Oh, Sean. Yeah.
可以说是反义词。我没说可以说是。你知道吗？我没说可以说是，但我说，这算什么狗屁娱乐圈。但你太不可思议了。你在喜剧这项运动中出类拔萃。对。哦，肖恩。对。
Oh, I don't know who it was, but I was listening backstage as best I could. And someone's, you said, time of the day, is it a sports person? You went, no, not a, kind of the opposite of a sports person. I swear I got one person way in the back, I was like, Conan. Oh. Oh.
哦，我不知道那是谁，但我尽我所能地在后台听着。然后有人——你当时说，“说实话，是个运动员吗？”你来了句，“不，不是，有点像运动员的反义词。”我发誓我在最后排听到有一个人喊出了：“柯南。”哦。哦。
Well, when did I become the dictionary definition of all that is not excellence in sport? What's the opposite of the most in my account? Oh. Oh. I would like to. Wow. I would like to... Wow.
好吧，我什么时候成了“体育界毫无卓越可言”的字典释义了？怎么就成了我这种体量的反义词了？哦。哦。我真想——哇。我真想——哇。
I would like to know, as we spoke during the last few years, during the pandemic, you chose to do something a little different with your hair, and now you're going back to the original. It's a great place to start. It's a great place to start. You're like, it's a place. You usually want to soften up the guests. No, it's good for you to start messing them up.
我真的很想知道，正如我们在过去几年里、在疫情期间所谈到的那样，你选择对你的头发做了一些不同的处理，而现在你又恢复了原样。这倒是个很好的切入点。这倒是个很好的切入点。你就像是——这算个切入点。你通常会想先给嘉宾留点面子。不，一上来就把他们搞砸对你挺好的。
No, I just... I don't know what it looks like, because... I can tell you this. It is raining ice outside. Yeah. And this podcast doesn't spend a lot of time. Oh, wow. We got you an umbrella, didn't we? By the way, no, you sent me half an umbrella. It should be noted, it should be noted.
不，我只是……我不知道它看起来怎么样，因为……我可以告诉你这个。外面下着冰雨。对。而且这个播客也没花多少时间。哦，哇。我们给你准备了一把伞，不是吗？顺便说一句，不，你只送了我半把伞。应该指出的是，这应该被指出来的。
So before the show, Jason Sean didn't know that Conan came all the way from California to see you guys. Yes, thank you. And all right. You need to walk. And he wrote his razor. So I go into his dressing room and somebody on our team has laid out a ton of smart-less swag, like hats and stuff.
所以在演出前，杰森和肖恩并不知道柯南大老远从加州来看你们。是的，谢谢。还有，好吧。你得走。而且他还带着他的剃须刀。所以我走进他的化妆间，我们团队的某个人摆出了一大堆 SmartLess 的周边，比如帽子之类的好东西。
And he's got his own podcast, and he is seething. Oh, I see this stuff, and I take a picture of it, and I send it his own podcast and he is seething. I see this stuff and I take a picture of it and I send it to my podcast people. We have a shower cap. There's a Colonel Brian, he's a friend, shower cap. And if you use it in the shower and it gets wet, you see that it used to be for Alf, the TV show Alf. Oh no. Old reference.
而他有自己的播客，他气得火冒三丈。哦，我看到了这些东西，我拍了张照片，然后发给了——他有自己的播客，他气得火冒三丈。我看到这些东西，拍了张照片，然后发给了我的播客团队。我们有一个浴帽。有个叫布莱恩上校（Colonel Brian）的朋友，他送的浴帽。如果你在洗浴时使用它并且弄湿了，你会发现它以前是为《阿夫》（Alf）——那个电视剧《阿夫》准备的。哦，不。老梗。
But anyway, I'll just lift this and put it over here. Yeah, you give me shit for old reference. Oh no. Old reference. But anyway, I'll just lift this and put it over here. Yeah, you give me shit for old references. Hey, come on. What was the hair strategy before you came back? I wanted to look like a puppet. A man puppet that you've parted out of wood. What did that look like?
不过话说回来，我只要把这个拿起来放到这边就行了。对，你因为老梗而嘲笑我。哦，不。老梗。不过话说回来，我只要把这个拿起来放到这边就行了。对，你因为老梗而嘲笑我。嘿，得了吧。你来之前头发是怎么设计的？我想要看起来像个木偶。一个用木头拼凑出来的男人偶。那看起来是什么样子的？
Well, when I was a kid, true story, and I love I cracked this. I cracked this, by the way, because. I'm fucking hair, though. Right now, it's just kicking. story and I love I crack this I crack this by the way I can hear though right now is just a kick it is an audio medium and you know you've got to use everything you can to boost so anyway what happened was it I got it wet and then I was like I'll be fine and I just ran a hair dryer through it and it looks like I've been electrocuted my apologies but, but this will be good, you know? No, this is really good.
嗯，当我还是个孩子的时候，真实的故事，我喜欢——我破解了这个。顺便说一句，我破解了这个，因为——我他妈的头发，不过。现在，它简直太棒了。故事，我喜欢——我破解了这个。顺便说一句，我能听到声音，不过现在——这太带劲了，这是一个音频媒介，你知道的，你得利用你能利用的一切来烘托气氛——所以不管怎样，事情是这样的，我把它弄湿了，然后我想：我没事的。我只是用吹风机吹了一下，结果看起来就像我被电击了一样。我很抱歉，但是，但是这效果会很好，你知道吗？不，这真的很好。
It looks great. It's good for your brand. Thank you. Yeah, listen, the first thing I want to get to, and this is a bit of a touch of you subject, not for you, but for Jason. So we're not going to talk about his incredible guest appearance on Will's new show, Murderville.
看起来很棒。对你的品牌很有利。谢谢。听着，我首先想谈的事情是——这算是一个有点敏感的话题，对你来说不是，但对杰森来说是。所以我们不打算谈他在威尔的新剧《荒野谜案》（Murderville）中的精彩客串。
Well, let's get that out of the way. That is. That's incredible. You were... Conan was unbelievable. murder bill. Well, let's get that out of the way. That out. Because it's incredible. You were... Conan was unbelievable. All improvisation. Jason, your resting stance is to have your hand on your dick.
好吧，我们把那件事抛开吧。那真的是。太不可思议了。你当时——《荒野谜案》。好吧，我们把那件事抛开吧。抛开那个。因为这太不可思议了。你当时——柯南太不可思议了。全都是即兴发挥。杰森，你平时的站姿就是把手放在你的小弟弟上。
It's incredible. No, I swear to God, he's looking at me if I was on the subway and you were sitting opposite me and doing that, I would call the police. And I would- Is anyone else noticing this? He's like this. Hey, what's going on with your hair? I know. What's with your hair, buddy?
这太不可思议了。不，我发誓，他看着我的样子，就好像我坐地铁时你坐在我对面然后做那种动作，我会报警的。而且我——还有别人注意到这一点吗？他就像这样。嘿，你头发怎么了？我知道。伙计，你头发怎么回事？
What did you put up with that? I said, I don't mind that. Here we go. I'm going to point it at Sean. Thank you. Thank you. Yes, thank you. Thank you for murder, Villal.
你怎么能忍受那个？我说，我不介意这个。我们走。我要把它指向肖恩。谢谢。谢谢。是的，谢谢。谢谢你出演《荒野谜案》。
Conan came on and had no idea what we were doing. I didn't see you until we started rolling. And you were thrown into this bizarre situation. You never tell you what's going on. Well, for Tracy, tell them what murder, Villal is. And by the way murder Ville's got an amazing reviews everywhere. Yeah, yeah, thank you. Yeah, well I think my favorite headlines so far is O'Brien saves our net with murder Ville
柯南来的时候根本不知道我们在干什么。直到我们开始开机我才见到你。然后你被扔进了这个离奇的状况里。他们从来不告诉你发生了什么。好吧，特蕾西，告诉大家什么是《荒野谜案》。顺便说一句，《荒野谜案》到处都是惊人的好评。对，对，谢谢。好吧，我想我目前最喜欢的标题是：“奥兰多——哦不，奥布莱恩用《荒野谜案》拯救了我们的电视网”
I didn't Is that is that one of them? Yeah, I wrote that in yeah in the O'Brien Gazette Who said the or not is that today? It's a really fun show to do, and what happens is you know nothing, and they just tell you basically all you know is you're the trainee, and you're gonna be paired up with a detective will. It's an improv show. It's an improv show, but we never talked about how scary that is,
我没有——那是其中之一吗？对，那是我写的，在《奥布莱恩公报》上。谁说的——哦不，是今天吗？这是一档做起来非常有趣的节目，情况是这样的，你什么都不知道，他们基本上只会告诉你，你是个练习生，你将和警探威尔搭档。这是一档即兴节目。这是一档即兴节目，但我们从来没有讨论过这有多吓人，
because quite literally, we, you're sequestered, and then you're just brought to the edge of a set, and they go and action. Right, that's the exact answer. Yes, the guest star is the only person that has to improvise. It has no script. The person who is most fearful gets no script, which is nice to be.
因为毫不夸张地说，我们——你被隔离了，然后你只是被带到片场的边缘，他们说“action”。没错，这绝对是标准答案。是的，客串明星是唯一必须即兴发挥的人。没有任何剧本。最胆小的人拿不到剧本，这挺不错的。
I actually find that liberating because you don't learn lines. You don't learn lines and people come in the room and say things like, Brian, you're just like, yes, chief. Let me ask you something. It's fun. You get salutingoting, everybody. Absolutely. Everybody.
我其实觉得这很解放天性，因为你不用背台词。你不用背台词，人们走进房间说一些诸如“奥布莱恩，你简直像……”这样的话，你只需回答：“是的，长官。”让我问你个问题。这很有趣。你们所有人都在敬礼。绝对的。所有人。
But when is the last time you had to learn lines? Because I was in all your stuff on Promptr. Don't hit me. It's not all on Promptr. Yes, I've never conquered the movie realm as all of you have. But one day I will, these cheekbones will not go to waste. No, but I mean like, is that something, like have you always wanted to do
但你上一次不得不背台词是什么时候？因为我在提词器上看到了你所有的东西。别打我。并非全都在提词器上。是的，我可没有像你们所有人那样征服电影界。但总有一天我会的，我这几根颧骨可不能白白浪费。不，我的意思是——这是那种事吗？就像你一直想演
like a regular scripted show? No, no, I never have. I've never wanted anything. I like to say things the minute I think of them, and I'm very happy in this, like this. That this silly world works, because I used to work. My job was to try and think of what's the cleverest thing and I loved it slash also found it to be incredibly difficult.
那种常规的有剧本的电视剧吗？不，不，我从来没有。我从来没想过任何事。我喜欢在我想到某件事的瞬间把它说出来，我对这种现状非常满意。这种愚蠢的世界行得通，因为我以前工作过。我的工作就是努力去想什么是绝顶聪明的事情，我爱这份工作——但同时也觉得它难得不可思议。
Well, when you started to go and you started to perform, obviously you maybe didn't have to learn a lot, but you did so many great classic sketches on all your shows that were unbelievable and you had the incredible you know sketch comedians working with you, the great stuff, but when you were writing sketches and things for other people, was that frustrating? No, I have to say, because I was writing,
嗯，当你开始做节目并开始表演时，显然你可能不需要背很多台词，但在你所有的节目中，你都做过那么多精彩绝伦的经典小品，那些小品不可思议，而且你还和那些了不起的喜剧演员合作过，那些棒极了的东西。但是当你为其他人写小品之类的内容时，这会让人沮丧吗？不，我必须说，因为我在写作——
I mean, this is a very, I'm sure a very young crowd, but so the... Our demo is very young. Yes, and for you. I know that's not true, but it's good for advertising. Where's that? Where's that? And by the way, thank you for your service in the Korean conflict.
我的意思是，这是一个非常——我确信这是一群很年轻的观众，所以……我们的观众群体非常年轻。是的，而且是为了你。我知道这不是真的，但这有利于广告招商。那是哪儿？那是哪儿？顺便说一句，谢谢你们在朝鲜战争中的服役。
I saw them loading in the crowd and you're like, I can do it myself. It better not be going in a bribe tonight. Oh, if it's calling! How did you shoot me? Um, but again, I'm getting incredible character work. You know, my character is, well, whatever. We won't get into it. There's Streep and Conan and what else is there? But, but writing sketches for other people. I was writing for, you know, Dana Carvey and Mike Myers
我看到他们把人群接进来，而你就像是在说：我自己能行。千万别在今晚惹恼奥布莱恩！哦，如果真惹了！你当时是怎么拍我的？嗯，不过话说回来，我得到了令人难以置信的角色塑造。你知道，我的角色是，嗯，不管怎样。我们就不展开了。有梅丽尔·斯特里普和柯南，还有什么来着？但是，但是为其他人写小品。我当时是在为——你知道的，达纳·卡维（Dana Carvey）和麦克·迈尔斯（Mike Myers）
and, you know, Adam Sandler and all these people. And I never looked at what they were doing and thought, that should be me. I knew that they could do these things that I couldn't really do. That wasn't what I was interested in. I knew that I had to be cone in myself to be funny. So I never envied them.
以及——你知道的，亚当·桑德勒（Adam Sandler）和所有这些优秀的人写东西。我从来没有看着他们的表演然后想：“那应该是我。”我知道他们能做到这些我 realmente 做不到的事情。那不是我感兴趣的。我知道我必须做回柯南自己才能搞笑。所以我从未嫉妒过他们。
I envied them the attention and all that. But those moments when you write something and you think like, oh, the joke would have been 15% better if they hit this. Like, did that ever happen? Those guys are so good. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I know.
我嫉妒过他们得到的关注和诸如此类的事情。但那些你写了某些东西然后觉得，哦，如果他们能把这个梗抖得再好15%的话就好了的时刻——这种事发生过吗？那些家伙太棒了。对，对，对。我知道。
They've got your old stories. And that's the thing is, I was working with people that were so great. I think if I have been working on some show that I didn't really respect, I might be thinking, why not me? Why not me? But I was never in that situation. When you say that you're really excited to do something
他们有你以前的故事。这就是重点，我当时合作的人都太伟大了。我想如果我是在某个我并不怎么尊重的节目里工作，我可能就会想：为什么不是我？为什么不是我说？但我从来没有处在那样的境况中。当你说你真的很兴奋能去做一些事情——
where you can say what you're thinking of right when you're thinking of it, like you can on your show. Or this medium. What we're trying to be disciplined about on this and on the podcast is not to get canceled by just saying the first thing that, like because like that happens. Yeah. How did you I would imagine how did you avoid it because honestly you're so right.
你可以把你脑子里想的直接说出来，就在你想到它的那个瞬间，就像你在你的节目上或在这个媒介上一样。我们在这次以及在播客中一直试图严格要求自己的是，不要因为随口说出第一件想到的事情而被封杀——因为那种事确实会发生。你是怎么——我想象不出你是怎么避免的，因为说实话，你太对了。
I you're so right to be canceled. I have a lot of I have a lot of controversial views that my friends know about and I'd like to air them out right here. Good idea. But when you're dealing with I believe science has yet to prove. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, go to no. Don't do it. Does anyone see the virus? I have it. I'm going to say the same thing.
你太有可能会被封杀了。我有很多——我有很多我的朋友们都知道的充满争议的观点，我非常想在这里公开阐述一下。好主意。但是当你处理——我相信科学尚未证实。等一下，等一下，等一下，等一下，等一下，等一下，等一下，等一下，别去了。别这么做。有人看到那个病毒了吗？我有。我要说同样的话。
I have to think to believe in something you can't see. Sounds like a religion to me. I'm just saying. What I was going to bring up was the touchy thing was that your Christmas party and that you didn't invite Bateman. Oh yeah, let's get it. And plus, not plus. So, wait a second.
我必须思考才能相信那些你看不见的东西。这听我听起来像个宗教。我只是随口说说。我本来想提的那个敏感的事，其实是关于你的圣诞派对，以及你没有邀请贝特曼。哦，对，我们来谈谈这个。而且，不止于此。所以，等一下。
So this is true, so I after... And of course. After I came to your, so Jimmy and I were there at your party and then we went over to our other friends after her and Jason was there and Bateman's like, where are you guys so late? And I said, oh well, we were at Conan's. Oh, you were at Conan's Christmas party?
所以这是真的，所以我去了——当然。在我去了你的——所以吉米和我当时都在你的派对上，然后我们去了另一个朋友那里，杰森当时也在那儿，然后贝特曼就问：“你们俩怎么这么晚？”我说：“哦，我们在柯南家。”“哦，你们在柯南的圣诞派对上？”
What, my phone number doesn't work? Yeah. Everybody at this other party was either fresh from your party, or set to leave for your party. Next plane, everybody. I can explain to you in one way or four hundred people. Yeah. There is one thing.
什么，我的电话号码不管用了吗？对。参加这个派对的每个人，要么刚从你的派对过来，要么正准备去你的派对。下一班飞机，所有人。我可以从一个或四百个方面向你解释。对。有一件事。
This is all so real. One, this is, there is a very simple reason why you have not been invited to my Christmas party and why you will never be invited to my Christmas party. And that's that you came to my house one time and you sat down, yes you did and you planted yourself in the corner. And on cock.
这一切都太真实了。第一，这是一个——有一个非常简单的原因，解释了为什么你没有被邀请参加我的圣诞派对，以及为什么你永远也不会被邀请参加我的圣诞派对。那就是你以前有一次去我家，你坐了下来——是的，你确实这么干了——你把自己钉在了角落里。还翘着二郎腿（on cock）。
And I have kids. I have little kids. And they got really uncomfortable. And I said, she's a nice guy. And he was like, yeah, I get on back here. No, I had like a legendary Bob Newhart comes to my party every year. One of the great comic icons of all time. And you people know, because you're all in your late 70s. And I can't have you sitting across from him rubbing up against him.
而且我有孩子。我有小孩子。他们感到非常不自在。我说，她是个好人。而他却说：“是的，我回后面去。”不，我的派对上每年都有传奇人物鲍勃·纽哈特（Bob Newhart）出席。史上最伟大的喜剧偶像之一。你们大家也都知道，因为你们都已经七十多岁了。我可不能让你坐在他对面还一直在他身上蹭来蹭去的。
I'm playing his son in a television series, you dick. Yeah, I know, I know. And guess what? You were doing it then, and he didn't like it then either. I was invited to that party. Yeah, that's all I have to say. But you didn't come. You didn. I was invited to that party. Yeah. That's all I have to say. But you didn't come.
我正在一部电视剧里演他的儿子呢，你个混蛋。对，我知道，我知道。你猜怎么着？你当时就在这么干，他当时也不喜欢这样。我被邀请去那个派对的。对，这就是我想说的全部。但你没去。你没去。我被邀请去那个派对的。对，这就是我想说的全部。但你没去。
You didn't come. I couldn't come. Couldn't come or wouldn't come. The last one. No. I couldn't make it. But I... You can't make it to a Conan O'Brien party.
你根本没去。我没去成。是不能去还是不想去？最后那个。不。我抽不出时间。但是，我……你竟然去不了一个柯南·奥布莱恩的派对。
If I sit in this crowd right now, we're all going back to Conan's place. Look at that! But this guy over here. I had previous engagements. I see. I don't know, you're pretty engaging. What are you doing?
如果我现在坐在台下这群观众里，我们所有人都会去柯南家了。你看！但这家伙在这儿。我之前有别的安排。我懂，你挺忙的。你在干嘛呢？
This is Sean with his dog. What's that dog's name? Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, let's get into it. Dickie, Ricky, Ricky. And he brings the dog, whatever he goes. I have a lot of anxiety, it's like a child because he's still a puppy. So I don't want to leave it alone for more than two hours
这是肖恩和他的狗。那只狗叫什么名字？哦，对，对，对，我们来聊聊这个。迪基（Dickie），里奇（Ricky），里奇。他去哪儿都带着那只狗。我有很多焦虑，它就像个孩子，因为他还是一只小狗。所以我不想把它单独留在家超过两个小时，
or say, freak out. But next year I will go. Also, we have a tradition at our Christmas party, which is called Catch the Puppy. Yeah, yeah. We toss it around and Sean knows about it. And I'm not going to let him. Like, they're going to do it.
否则它会抓狂的。不过明年我会去的。另外，我们的圣诞派对上有一个传统，叫做“抓住小狗”。对，对。我们把它抛来抛去，肖恩对此心知肚明。我才不会让他——他们会这么干的。
And it was so. And we will be right back. Thank you to True Classic for supporting the show. Now this is my favorite time of the year, right? We've got summer here. So it's beach parties, barbecues hanging out of the beach. You name it. And while I love the warmer weather, boy can be hard to dress for the heat, right guys?
节目马上回来。感谢 True Classic 对本节目的大力支持。现在是一年中最棒的时光，对吧？夏天到了。有海滩派对、烧烤聚会、在海滩上闲逛。应有尽有。虽然我喜欢温暖的天气，但说实话，应对高温穿衣确实挺难的，对吧伙计们？
Listen, huh? Don't we all have those little clothes fits in the summer? Men, you know what I'm talking about, right? Especially for us guys, right? We want to be comfortable in a t-shirt that fits great, right? Because listen, there's only a couple of Bradpits in the world. The rest of us, you know, it's not great under the T-shirts. You want the T-shirt to help make things great.
听着，哈？难道我们在夏天不都有那些衣服不合身的烦恼吗？男士们，你们知道我在说什么，对吧？特别是对我们这些大老爷们儿来说，对吧？我们希望穿着舒适，穿一件版型极佳的T恤，对吧？因为听着，世界上没几个布拉德·皮特。剩下我们大多数人，你知道的，穿T恤的身材并不是那么完美。你希望T恤能帮你把一切修饰得完美。
And this is why I love true classic. Because they make it easy to look and feel great all summer along with their perfect fitting shirts, shorts, and pants, all the prices that your wallet will also love. All right, so let's talk about these true classic teas for one second. I've been blown away by how perfectly this thing fits me. I mean, the draping on it, right?
这就是我为什么喜欢 True Classic。因为他们让你在这个夏天轻松拥有好气色和好状态，秘诀就在于他们完美剪裁的衬衫、短裤和裤子，而且价格也非常亲民。好了，让我们花一分钟来聊聊 True Classic 的这些T恤。我被这件衣服完美合身的剪裁彻底惊艳到了。我是说，它下垂的线条感，对吧？
The cut of it. The hang on it and everything. It's like my new secret weapon. It makes me look super fit because I'm not. With the way that it hugs my arms and my chest. Now, these arms, my forearms are bigger than my biceps. I need to lift weight and I don't have the discipline to do that.
它的剪裁。它垂坠的质感等等。这简直就像我的全新秘密武器。它让我看起来超级健美，尽管我其实并没有。它完美包裹着我的手臂和胸部。现在，我的手臂，我的前臂比我的二头肌还要粗。我需要去举铁，但我又没有那个毅力。
The way that the T-shirt falls on me, I need the help. True classic helps me, right? It's just the right amount of room through the body on this shirt. Even better, they got this new summer ready color. You know, lots of them. All these different summer colors, they come in packs.
这件T恤落在我身上的版型，我真的很需要这种帮助。True Classic 帮了我大忙，对吧？这件衣服在身躯部分的预留空间恰到好处。更棒的是，他们推出了全新的夏日专属色。你知道的，有很多种颜色。所有这些不同的夏日色彩，都是成包出售的。
So you can have a shirt for every day of the week. You don't even have to do any laundry, the lazy bump. So if you're ready to upgrade your look and your wardrobe shop now at TrueClassic.com and save 25% off with the code, smartness. Look your best, feel your best, be your best with TrueClassic. Are you the warrior of your friend group? Doom scrolling late into the night, researching all the survival scenarios you may find yourself in, stop scrolling, grab your weighted blanket and your headphones because we have a new podcast to help you cope.
所以你一周七天每天都能穿一件。你甚至都不用洗衣服，你这个懒虫。所以如果你准备好升级你的造型和衣橱，现在就去 TrueClassic.com 购物，使用优惠码 smartness 即可享受 75 折优惠。穿出最佳状态，感受最佳状态，成就最佳状态，就选 TrueClassic。你是你朋友圈里的末日生存狂吗？深夜还在疯狂刷手机、研究你可能遭遇的各种生存场景？别再刷了，抓紧你的厚重毛毯和耳机，因为我们有一档新播客来帮你的焦虑找到出口。
From Wondry, don't panic! Leans into our most absurd anxieties and diffuses them with humor and actual advice for how to deal should you find yourself facing your fears. Hosted by anxious and overly informed comedian Anthony Ataminik, each week explores a worst-case scenario, like what do you do if you encounter a bear or a swarmah killer bee, or find yourself stuck in quicksand. Each episode's panic of the week will make you laugh, learn, and sure, possibly sweat profusely. Enjoy Don't Panic on the
来自 Wondry 的《别慌！》（Don't Panic!）深入探讨了我们最荒谬的焦虑，并用幽默和切实的建议来化解它们，教你如果真的直面恐惧该如何应对。由焦虑且消息灵通的喜剧演员安东尼·阿塔米尼克（Anthony Ataminik）主持，每周探讨一个最坏的情况，比如如果你遇到一熊或一群杀人蜂，或者发现自己陷入流沙该怎么办。每一集的“每周恐慌”都会让你开怀大笑、学到知识，当然，可能还会让你大汗淋漓。在 Wondry App 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《别慌！》。
Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Don't Panic early and add free on Wondry Plus. Join Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. Join Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. I'm Rex Chapman and these days most people know me for trolling weirdos on the internet, which is fun. But believe it or not, I had a whole career before that, playing basketball in the NBA. Chapman 3 pointer outside! I played for four teams over 12 years in the league, alongside so many incredible players. But no matter where
你可以在 Wondry Plus 上提前收听并免广告收听《别慌！》。加入 Wondry App 或 Apple Podcasts 上的 Wondry Plus。加入 Wondry App 或 Apple Podcasts 上的 Wondry Plus。我是雷克斯·查普曼（Rex Chapman），如今大多数人因为我在网上调侃怪咖而认识我，这挺有意思的。但信不信由你，在此之前我有一整段职业生涯，曾在 NBA 打篮球。查普曼在三分线外出手命中！我在联盟效力了 12 年，呆过四支球队，身边有那么多不可思议的球员。但无论我走到哪里，
I went, there was one guy on every team who was totally untouchable. That was the owner. Plenty of fans don't even know who owns their team, who's making the backroom deals and moving players around like pieces on a game board. But every week on OND, we're going to take the fancy elevator sneak pass security and find out what it means to be a power player in the big leagues of pro sports. You know, I said I keep giving the money, but they keep getting the same result. The family is like the wealthy but un-sixie Kardashians.
每个队里总有一个绝对惹不起的人。那就是老板。很多粉丝甚至不知道谁是他们球队的老板，是谁在幕后做交易、把球员像棋盘上的棋子一样移来移去。但每周在 OND，我们将乘坐豪华电梯绕过安检，去探究在职业体育的大联盟里成为一个权力玩家到底意味着什么。你知道，我说过我会一直给他们资金，但他们得到的结果却总是千篇一律。这家人就像是一群富有却一点都不性感的卡戴珊。
Follow OND wherever you get your podcast. You can listen early and add free on the Amazon Music or One Dread app. And now back to the show. Wait, I want to ask you something because you've been so successful at being a host and a talk show host for all of those years. You're always at the top of your game. One of the funniest, if not the funniest, toast of all time. And I think. And, not-and- no. Yeah. Even the best audio editor in the world can't fix that gap. LAUGHTER Between what Sean said and entire Wang Center
在任何你获取播客的地方订阅 OND。你可以在 Amazon Music 或 Wondry App 上提前且免广告收听。现在回到节目中。等等，我想问你一件事，因为你这么多年来作为主持人和脱口秀主持人取得了巨大的成功。你一直处于你的巅峰状态。最有趣的主持人之一，如果不是史上最有趣的话。而且我认为。而且，不——不。对。即使是世界上最好的音频剪辑师也无法弥补这个空白。（笑声）在肖恩说的话和整个王氏剧院（Wang Center）
filled with bus juniors going, yeah! I'll try it again. One of the funniest... One of the nine best. If not the funniest toast of all time. Please. Please keep in the original. But then take me through it.
坐满了发出“耶！”的波士顿年轻人之间！我再试一次。最有趣的主持人之一……九大最有趣的主持人之一。如果不是史上最有趣的主持人。拜托。请保留原声。但然后带我回顾一下。
But then take me through it because you did late night with Conan. That was the first one, right? Yeah. Then you did the tonight show. Yeah. You're picturing it. No, no, because I don't want to miss one. And then you did your own show on TBS, right? Yeah, called Conan.
但接着带我回顾一下，因为你主持过《柯南深夜秀》（Late Night with Conan）。那是第一个，对吧？对。然后你主持了《今夜秀》（The Tonight Show）。对。你在脑海里想象。不，不，因为我不想漏掉任何一个。然后你在 TBS 上有了你自己的节目，对吧？对，叫做《柯南》（Conan）。
That's right. And then, thank God, how did you guys come up with that? Yeah, I was a bit of a bit. But now you have this incredibly successful podcast. What is it about hosting and interviewing people? Have you ever gotten tired of just like, But now you have this incredibly successful podcast. What is it about hosting and interviewing people? Have you ever gotten tired of just like, the forum interviewing? Yeah.
没错。然后，谢天谢地，你们是怎么想出那个的？对，这算是一个小小的梗。但现在你拥有了这个极其成功的播客。主持节目和采访别人到底有什么魔力？你有没有对这种形式的采访感到厌倦过？——但现在你拥有了这个极其成功的播客。主持节目和采访别人到底有什么魔力？你有没有对这种形式的采访感到厌倦过？对。
I find this to be really fun. This is just, and I will say the first thing I think to myself, when I leave a stage like this, I'll think this tonight, the first thing I'll leave. A, I'll think I was not paid. Um... LAUGHTER LAUGHTER I got a smart-less beer cozy, because...
我发现这真的很有趣。这简直——我要说的是，每当我离开像这样的舞台时，我首先脑子里想到的，今晚我也会这么想，我离开时首先想到的会是：第一，我会觉得自己根本没拿片酬。嗯……（笑声）（笑声）我只拿到一个 SmartLess 的啤酒保温套，因为……
LAUGHTER We all know how much I love me a beer cozy. Yeah. And then... I will... The thing I will think about when I leave is, this is not a job. I said this to you when I was on your podcast, you find three people, any one of whom I'd be delighted to hang out with and screw around with.
[笑声] 我们都知道我有多喜欢啤酒保温套。没错。然后……我会……我离开时脑子里想的是，这不是一份工作。我上你的播客时就对你这么说过，你找到了三个人，他们中的任何一个我都乐意跟他们混在一起、胡闹。
This is handed by two to a party. Well, hang out with and screw around with this is how you buy two to a party well He's hand off cop and maybe Yeah, the invitation start to flow But was there ever a point was there a point where it did feel laborious and you're like yeah, yeah Little bit right there Well, you're no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, And it doesn't mean you have to yell, but yeah. OK, it's called a volume business. And so I did four or five shows a week for 28 years. And what happens sometimes is that you're waiting for the blog.
这就像是两人一起去参加派对。好吧，跟他们混在一起、胡闹，这就是你怎么买到两人派对的门票。好吧，他把手拿开，也许吧。是的，邀请函开始源源不断地飞来。但有没有那么一个时刻，有没有一个时刻让你觉得这真的很费劲，你会想，对，对，就在那一小会儿。好吧，你不是……不不不不不不不不不不不不……我的意思是，你不需要大喊大叫，但是，是的。好吧，这叫做走量业务。所以我连续28年，每周做四到五场节目。有时候会发生的情况是，你在等那个段子。
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. People are 28 years. 28 years. Yeah, we did 4,600 shows. And you know what, I'm told, seven are quite good. But that's so impressive. Yeah, the thing is, of course, there's a part where it's a night where, I mean,
不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。人们常说28年。28年。是的，我们做了4600场节目。你知道吗，据我所知，有七场相当不错。但这太让人印象深刻了。是的，关键是，当然，有些夜晚，我的意思是，
one of my favorite stories ever is the hilarious. One of the funniest people that you will all attest is one of the funniest people ever is mr. Martin short. Yeah, I'm sure is just a best a treasure. He is one of maybe all of us I think when he's around we all like we like okay, okay, it's Martin short So there was a night many years ago where I'm and I've been doing this for years and years and I'm slogging through and unlike tonight, you know doing this for years and years and I'm slogging through. And unlike tonight, let's say, because you're doing so
我最喜欢的搞笑故事之一。你们所有人都会作证说，史上最搞笑的人之一就是马丁·肖特先生。是的，肖特简直是个极品，是个宝藏。他可能是……我们大家觉得当他在场时，我们都会觉得，好吧，好吧，是马丁·肖特。所以很多年前的一个晚上，当时……我已经做这个节目很多年很多年了，我正艰难地挺过去，不像今晚，你知道的……做这个节目很多年很多年了，我正艰难地挺过去。跟今晚不同，比方说，因为你做了这么
many shows and you're doing three guests tonight, sometimes there's a guest on who maybe you don't want to talk to, but you have to. And it's 120 in the morning, and they're here, and you might as well deal with it. And that's definitely pointed to you. I definitely was appointed to you. No, no, no.
多场节目，今晚你要采访三位嘉宾，有时候会遇到这样的嘉宾：也许你根本不想跟他说话，但你又不得不说。当时是凌晨1点20分，他们就在这儿，你也只能硬着头皮应付。这话绝对是冲着你来的。我绝对是冲着你来的。不，不，不。
But what happened? What happened? Where it is, see? So Martin Short was the first guest just destroys, hilarious. Then he moves down the couch and he's right where you are. And I'm sitting here and the next guest comes and I'm not being meaner and I think I honestly don't remember who it was. It was an actress who had been modeling, but now she was transitioning into acting.
但后来怎么了？后来怎么了？结果是，你看！所以马丁·肖特是第一位嘉宾，简直把全场炸翻了，太搞笑了。然后他挪到沙发另一头，坐到了现在你坐的位置。我坐在这儿，下一位嘉宾上场了——我可不是故意刻薄，说实话我真的记不清那是谁了。那是一位当过模特的女演员，但现在她正转型当演员。
And her, oh, what a story. Yeah. And her publicists had said, like, make sure you get that in that she's transitioning now into acting, because we're moving to the next phase. I love that you don't want to say it is, but yet we can Google Conan O'Brien Marty Shor. There's probably three choices.
她……哦，真是个故事。对。她的公关曾说过，一定要提一下她现在正在转型当演员，因为我们要进入下一个阶段了。我喜欢你不想说是谁，但我们其实可以在谷歌上搜索“柯南·奥布莱恩 马蒂·肖特”。可能也就三个选项。
But this means I have it both ways. I'm a nice guy. Right. But fuck whoever that is. No, anyway. So, no. So anyway, I'm sitting in the chair. This person comes out.
但这意味著我两全其美。我是个好人。没错。但管他妈是谁呢。不管怎样。所以，不。总之。所以，我坐在椅子上。这个人走了出来。
They sit next to me and Martin Schwartz write where you are. And I'm getting through the interview, and then I see that question. And it's just an awkward lame question. But I got to do my job. And I'm like, that's a moment where I thought, I really wish I wasn't here. So I went.
她坐在我旁边，马丁·肖特就坐在你现在的位置。我好不容易熬过了采访，然后我看到了那个问题。那是一个既尴尬又蹩脚的问题。但我得完成我的工作。我想，就是在这个时候，我心想，我真希望自己不在这里。所以我去了……
So anyway, yeah, this'm like, that's a moment where I thought, I really wish I wasn't here. So I went, so anyway, yeah, that's great. That's a funny story. You know, I'm curious. You were a model, and you modeled for a long time. And now you're transitioning to acting. Which one do you prefer? Do you prefer the modeling or the acting? And she paused before she answered, and Marty's right where will is, and leans forward
所以总之，对，就像——我心想，就是在这个时候，我心想，我真希望自己不在这里。所以我去了，所以总之，对，那太棒了。这是个有趣的故事。你知道，我很好奇。你曾是一名模特，你当了很久的模特。现在你正在转型当演员。你更喜欢哪一个？你更喜欢当模特还是当演员？她回答前停顿了一下，马蒂就坐在威尔现在的位置上，身体前倾，
so that only I can see him, not the audience, and goes. I'm not going to say that. I'm not going to say that. I'm not going to say that. I'm not going to say that. I'm not going to say that. I'm not going to say that. I'm not going to say that.
好让只有我能看见他，观众看不见，然后他说……我才不说呢。我才不说呢。我才不说呢。我才不说呢。我才不说呢。我才不说呢。我才不说呢。
I'm not going to say that. I'm not going to say that. I'm not going to say that. I'm not going to say that. I'm not going to say that. I'm not going to say that. I'm not going to say that., I can't wait to hear. I'm hanging on every way. Oh. So I start, it sounds like what am I going to say. I start to laugh, but I'm biting on the start of my mouth,
我才不说呢。我才不说呢。我才不说呢。我才不说呢。我才不说呢。我才不说呢。我才不说呢。我等不及要听了。我正拭目以待呢。哦。所以我开始——听起来我到底要说什么。我开始笑，但我咬着嘴唇的边缘，
you start my mouth going, and she's saying, well, you know, it's tricky, I love modeling, but also acting, but then there's acting within smartling, and then, and he's going, woohoo! Woo! The whole time! And I'm losing it, and I, and he's going, oh, the whole time. And I'm losing it, and I'm biting so hard,
开始咬着嘴唇，而她说，嗯，你知道，这挺棘手的，我喜欢模特，但也喜欢表演，不过模特行业里也有表演，然后，然后他在那儿喊：“呜呼！呜！”全程都在喊！我快疯了，我——而且他一直在喊“哦——”全程都在喊。我快疯了，我咬得太紧了，
I'm bleeding in my mouth. And then I go like, anyway, no, she's talking to you, she's really good to talk to you. Thank you very, we take a break, we'll do it right back. Band plays, and I get up, and I walk around the couch, and Marty's sitting there acting like he had done nothing. And I leaned in and sit into his ear while the band's playing. I'm just trying to make a living, you fucking asshole. like he had done nothing, and I leaned in and sit into his ear while the band's playing.
嘴里都流血了。然后我说：好吧，不，她在跟你说话，她真的很擅长跟你聊天。非常感谢，我们休息一下，马上回来。乐队演奏，我站起来，绕过沙发，马蒂坐在那里，装得好像什么也没干过一样。乐队演奏时，我凑过去，贴着他的耳边说：“我只是在混口饭吃，你个他妈的混蛋。”装得好像什么也没干过一样，乐队演奏时，我凑过去，贴着他的耳边说：
I'm just trying to make a living, you fucking asshole. Yeah. He and I talk about that all the time. Like, you know, he took a moment that was like, oh shit, this is a job, too. That's one of the favorite things that's ever happened. What was somebody like Martin Short, you don't have to stick to the pre sort of deter,
“我只是在混口饭吃，你个他妈的混蛋。”没错。他和我有空就会聊起这个。就像，你知道的，他抓住了那个时刻，让人觉得，哦操，这也是一份工作。这是发生过最棒的事情之一。像马丁·肖特这样的人，你不需要局限于预先设定的那种……
cause for Tracy, when, when, when, when, when something, and let's hear it for Tracy. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We are, just, this is a quick sideline. We are going to see Tracy soon, aren't we?
为了特蕾西，当、当、当、当、当有事情发生时，让我们为特蕾西欢呼吧。对。对。我们正……这只是一个快速的小插曲。我们很快就要见到特蕾西了，对吧？
Yeah, we're gonna see Tracy. We're really excited. We're going to mess it. And for those who don't know, Tracy is Sean Sister, who doesn't know a lot about the business, and so we always have to do an aside. Wait, we're now doing for people who don't know who Tracy is. Yeah.
对，我们要去见特蕾西。我们非常兴奋。我们要搞砸它。对于那些不知道的人来说，特蕾西是肖恩的妹妹，她对这个行业不太了解，所以我们总是得扯开话题。等等，我们现在是在为那些不知道特蕾西是谁的人做解释吗？对。
It's got so fucking matter. Wow. So, anyway. So there's so you usually, you don't predetermine how the interview is going to go, but you talk with somebody who works for the talk show host, and you kinda say, well, what subjects are you comfortable talking about? And you kinda work out where an interview could go. What the questions might be, what the answers might be.
这他妈太无语了。哇。所以，总之。所以通常情况下，你不会预先决定采访会怎么进行，但你会跟脱口秀主持人的工作人员聊聊，然后你大概会说，嗯，你擅长聊哪些话题？你大概会探讨采访可能会走向何方。可能会有什么问题，可能会有什么回答。
That's sort of like a failsafe if somebody doesn't know how to have a conversation. What do you say the ratio is between guests that stick to the questions because of their comfort level or lack of conversation skills? And those you can just kind of freestyle like Marty. People that freestyle are very rare. Super rare. And you know what's interesting, absolutely true, I've noticed this over all these years of doing this, which is that there's something about the United Kingdom.
这有点像是一个安全网，以防有人不知道该怎么聊天。你觉得那些因为感到舒适或缺乏聊天技巧而死守问题不放的嘉宾，跟那些能像马蒂那样自由发挥的嘉宾，比例是多少？能够自由发挥的人非常罕见。超级罕见。而且你知道有趣的是，绝对千真万确，这些年来我做节目一直注意到这一点，那就是，英国似乎有一种特殊的魔力。
There's something about guests that have come from that environment. They are racontours. They tell a story. And I swear to God, years and years and years of talking to just terrific, great story British actors. And they almost need a pre-interview. You can just talk to them and they're funny and lovely and they're finishing your sentence and there's this. What's it? I've got to say in the British accent. Would you say?
从那种环境里出来的嘉宾身上总有一种特质。他们很会讲故事。我向上帝发誓，多年来跟无数极好的、伟大的英国故事大王演员聊天。他们几乎不需要预先采访。你只要跟他们聊天，他们就很搞笑、很可爱，还能接上你的话尾，而且……怎么说来着？我得用英国口音说。你觉得呢？
I said in Susanne. No, but when I was when I was younger just starting in the business they all talk to us they instilled the fear of God and you about sticking to the question. But that's a mistake. I would always say, I would always say, I would sometimes go on other talk shows and they would sort of start in the early days
我用苏珊娜的语气说的。不，但当我更年轻、刚入行的时候，他们所有人都会对我们说，他们会在你心中种下对“死守问题”的极度恐惧。但那是个错误。我总是说，我总是说，有时候我会去上别的脱口秀节目，在早期的时候，
to promote my talk show and they would drill me on the story, like say it again, say it again and I think that's not how human beings interact and people at home can tell this is kind of phony. If you had a time machine, was that the thing you would go and change? We never did that. We didn't do that.
他们会为了宣传我的脱口秀而对我进行特训，比如把这个故事再讲一遍，再讲一遍。我觉得人类的互动根本不是这样的，电视机前的观众一眼就能看出这是在装假。如果你有一台时间机器，那是你会回去改变的事情吗？我们从没那样做过。我们没那样做。
There's other things I would change. I would change a lot of things. When you go and seek out a young shone, and say, this is a mistake. Well, there's so many people I would go to and say, this is a mistake. I want to get back to the time machine. Yes, where would you take it?
还有别的事我会改变。我会改变很多事。当你去找年轻的肖恩，然后说，这是个错误。好吧，有太多人我会去找他们说，这是个错误。我想回到时间机器的话题上来。是的，你要把它开到哪里去？
What would you do? Okay, fascinating question. Yeah, it's right off the top of it. By the way, you're not using it right now or are you didn't come from the future? I did. What the fuck? This piebass you can never have a year to go.
你会做什么？好吧，迷人的问题。是的，一上来就问这个。顺便说一句，你现在没在用它吧？还是说你其实是从未来来的？我是。什么鬼？这台时光机你永远也开不到一年后。
No. Yeah, shoot, I'm sorry. It's hugely successful. Who does drops off? Who dies, Conan? Who dies? No, no, no one dies. Wait, that's just hidden.
不。是啊，见鬼，我很抱歉。它取得了巨大的成功。谁退出了？谁死了，柯南？谁死了？不，不，不，没人死。等等，那是剧透吗？
Conan. Where is that? Oh, shit. Let's just say one of you gets canceled because you decide to take public transportation. And you start a little crotch fire. No, no, no, I am coming from the future to tell you, enjoy this while it lasts. Oh, God.
柯南。在哪儿？哦，操。比方说，你们其中一个人因为决定乘坐公共交通工具而被全网封杀。然后你引发了一场胯部大火。不，不，不，我是从未来回来的，来告诉你们，及时行乐吧。哦，天哪。
You spent way too much money on very dangerous merchandise. What would you do with the time machine? Oh, my favorite question. It's a terrible question. No one's question. Well, what about a raw concert? You got to go back in time to see one band that no longer is together.
你在非常危险的周边商品上花太多钱了。你会用时间机器做什么？哦，我最喜欢的问题。这是个糟糕的问题。没人问过这种问题。好吧，那摇滚音乐会呢？你得回到过去看一支已经解散的乐队。
I would go back and see me. I'd see Holland Oates just before they broke up for the last time, two years ago. They reunited like 15 times. I'd go back and see him one last. No. Just kidding. Two, two, two.
我会回去看我自己。我会去看霍尔与奥茨乐队（Hall & Oates）在两年前最后一次解散前的演出。他们复合过大约15次。我会回去看他们最后一次。不。开玩笑的。二、二、二。
Or like, I love the idea that it's a group that broke up like a year ago and that's the group I want to see again. I want to go see the temptations not the one with the original guy. No, like they're two original guys suck. I saw them two years ago in Atlantic City. I want to go back in time and relive that. I lost my parking validation. You want to go to the set you want to go back in time and relive that. Because I lost my parking validation. You want to go to the set, you want to go to the set of the music video of the Beach Boys co-comal. LAUGHTER
或者说，我很喜欢这种设定——这是一个在一年前刚解散的乐队，而这就是我想再次观看的乐队。我想去看“诱惑乐队”（The Temptations），不是原班人马那个。不，就是有两个原班人马的那种，太逊了。我两年前在大西洋城看过他们。我想回到过去重温那一幕。我弄丢了停车验证小票。你想去那个场景，你想回到过去重温那一幕。因为我弄丢了停车验证小票。你想去那个场景，你想去海滩男孩《Kokomo》MV的拍摄现场。 [笑声]
Do you have any questions for Conan? Did you do knowing that he is a racon tour? Did you think that you did? You're the great. Maybe. Yeah. Did you think you didn't need any questions? I did.
你对柯南有什么问题吗？你知道他是个擅长讲故事的人，你觉得你需要准备吗？你太棒了。也许吧。是的。你觉得自己不需要准备任何问题吗？我是这么想的。
I do have some questions. But now that we're in a conversation, what am I going to ask in one of Sean's questions? Right, right, right. That's color. Well, we already covered time machines. Yeah. Can I ask a question?
我确实有些问题。但既然我们已经聊起来了，我还要问肖恩的那些问题吗？对，对，对。这就是点缀。好吧，我们已经讨论过时间机器了。是的。我能问个问题吗？
You guys famously, and it's a brilliant idea and a big fan of the show, two of you never know who the guest is. You're not prepared. One of you does know of the guest is, so you're not prepared. One of you does know. Of the people who are unprepared, who's just the worst at just coming up with something? Come on, Will, come on. I'm probably the worst.
你们俩有个著名的传统——这也是个绝妙的主意，我是这档节目的超级粉丝——你们俩永远不知道嘉宾是谁。你们没有做准备。其中一个人确实知道嘉宾是谁，所以你们没做准备。其中一个人是知道的。在那些没有做准备的人当中，谁最不擅长临场发挥？得了吧，威尔，得了吧。我可能最不在行。
I'm the worst. Have you ever been talking to someone and you just didn't even know who they were? Yes. Who? Well, I don't want to say. Well, there he is. Grandma doesn't really know a lot. Well, my favorite thing is on this show project runway,
我最不在行。你有没有过跟某人聊天，却根本不知道对方是谁的经历？有。谁？好吧，我不想说。好吧，瞧他那样。奶奶其实也知道得不多。好吧，我最喜欢看这档节目《天桥骄子》（Project Runway），
which my wife and kids, OK, whenever they bring out, they say, guess what? We got a special. And they bring out these amazing people sometimes. I guess I don't know a lot about fashion, but sometimes they clearly couldn't get someone. OK, that's nice. No, that's an ice storm to get here.
我老婆和孩子——好吧，每当他们推出新节目时，他们就会说，猜怎么着？我们有个特别节目。有时候他们会请来这些了不起的人物。我想我可能对时尚了解不多，但有时候他们显然是请不到什么大腕。好吧，那挺好的。不，能来这儿就不错了。
And so I'm watching it, and every now and then they'll be like, guess who are our special judges this week? And they'll say, you know, it's Heinrich Liebman. And you can tell that they've told the contestants you have to act like Jesus has come in. Yeah. And they're like, ah! And then they cut to the interview right part where they go,
所以我看节目的时候，每隔一段时间他们就会说：“猜猜我们这周的特邀评委是谁？”然后他们会说，你知道的，是海因里希·利布曼（Heinrich Liebman）。你可以看出他们已经对参赛选手说了：“你们得表现得像耶稣降临一样。”是的。然后他们会大喊：“啊！”接着镜头切到采访片段，他们会说：
I can't believe what's going on. It's Heinrich Liebman. It's Heinrich Liebman. But I don't know who the person is. And I know that that would be, for example, and I'm not name dropping, though maybe I might be. I recently, the last person I interviewed for my podcast was Supreme Court Justice Sonia Sotomayor. Now, I'm live.
“我简直不敢相信眼前发生的一切。是海因里希·利布曼！是海因里希·利布曼！”但我根本不知道这人是谁。我知道这会是——比如说，我可不是在炫耀名人朋友圈，虽然我可能确实在炫耀。我最近，我为我的播客采访的最后一个人是最高法院大法官索尼娅·索托马约尔。现在，我是现场连线。
Thank you. That's a nice booking. Yeah. Oh, wait, Supreme Court Justice don't do interviews. Exactly. Wow. So, anyway, achieving the impossible, I think, is our goal in this industry.
谢谢。这是个很棒的嘉宾预约。等等，最高法院大法官不上这种访谈节目吧。没错。哇。所以，总之，在这个行业里，实现不可能的事情我想就是我们的目标。
So, what I did is I studied because you've got to know your shit when you're talking to Supreme Court Justice and I was thinking, what if I had just been on this show and Supreme Court Justice sort of my or came out and sat down and then, yeah, and well, no, you're doing that. Bateman's rubbing himself in the corner. And he's like, would you want a cheese doodle?
所以，我做了功课，因为你要是跟最高法院大法官对话，你得言之有物。当时我在想，如果我刚刚正在上这个节目，然后最高法院大法官索托马约尔走出来坐下，接着，对，好吧，不，你正在这么干。贝特曼在角落里自己搓着呢。他就像是在说，你想要一块芝士条吗？
Or like a nacho cheese. Do you want some puffy cheese? But see, by the way, do you remember the name of the show is Smart List? Yes, yes. Listen, when you guys, true story, these guys were drift, came to me a couple of years ago. Oh my god.
还是纳乔芝士味的？你想吃点膨化芝士吗？但话说回来，你们还记得这个节目的名字叫《聪明糊涂账》（SmartLess）吗？是的，是的。听着，当你们——说真的，几年前这两个家伙来找我。哦天哪。
And they knew that I was had a huge podcast, and they were like, what do we do? And I was like, guys, you're each individually funny. I said, two of you really have the goods. And I said, and I said, you'll be great together. And they're like, no, no, no, no, no. And I mean, it was embarrassing. My daughter was there and said, where are those grown men
他们知道我有一个超火的播客，然后他们问：“我们该怎么办？”我当时就说：“伙计们，你们每个人单拎出来都很搞笑。我说，你们俩确实很有两下子。我说，而且我说，你们俩在一起会非常棒。”他们就说：“不，不，不，不，不。”我的意思是，当时太尴尬了。我女儿当时也在场，问：“那些成年男人在那儿哭什么呢？”我当时说：“我来处理这件事。”我接着说：“伙计们，放松点。你们会很棒的。”而且模式应该是这样的。
crying? And I said, I'll handle this. And I said, guys, just relax. You're going to be great. And the format should be. And I remember, you guys were like, what's going on? And I said, just how about two of you don't know who the guest is and call it, dumb brain or something.
我记得，你们当时一脸懵：“到底怎么回事？”我说：“不如这样，你们俩中有一个人不知道嘉宾是谁，然后把节目叫作‘笨脑筋’或者别的什么名字。”你们当时就说：“这行不通吧。”然后你们就跑了。哭得稀里哗啦的。你们骑着那种小小的小孩自行车逃跑了。骑过山丘时还互相撞在一起。继续。
And you guys were like, maybe not a work. And you ran away. And you got on lot of crying. You got on small little, little child's bicycles and drove away. And you were banging into each other as you went over the hill. Go on.
不，你们得担心一下《聪明糊涂账》是怎么诞生的，克里斯。你们以前听过柯南的播客吧？你们很多人都听过。这是个很棒的播客。谢谢。我也上过好几次。你们应该让贝特曼也去上一次。对。对。我们挺好的。而且那里面有你，还有那些为你工作、觉得——不得不笑的人，所以因为
No, you got to worry of how smartless was Chris. You guys have heard Conan's podcast before, right? A lot of you. It's a great podcast. Thank you. And I've done it a couple of times. You ought to get Bateman on there. Yeah. Yeah. And we're good. And it's you and in people who work for you and who feel who have to who are obligated to laugh. So because
他们的工作取决于此，对吧？真的吗？不仅仅是他们的工作取决于此。如果他们不笑，会有痛苦，会有肉体上的痛苦。我绝对会打我手底下的人。你喜欢……瞧，我被全网封杀了。哦，不。你还在纳闷这事什么时候会发生呢。你看你离被封杀有多近？我知道。
their jobs depend on it, right? Is that true? It's not just that their jobs depend on it. If they don't laugh, pain, there's physical pain. I'm not above hitting someone who works for me. Do you like? And there I got canceled. Oh, no. You were wondering when it would happen. Did you see how close you are? I know it was.
永远都在边缘试探。让我问你，算了，因为这个问题。太无聊了。每个人都在问：“现在当喜剧演员有多难？”其实没那么难。你只要他妈的——对吧？一点都不难。但确实有那种时候，你会有某些时刻。
Always on the edge. Let me ask you, forget it, because this is the question. It's so boring. Everybody's like, how hard is it to be a comedian right now? It's not that hard. You just fucking, right? It's not hard at all. But there is that thing you have moments.
是的，没有。回到杰森的问题。比如，你如何剪辑你的内容？有没有你想说的话，但你必须马上自我审查？哦，杰森的问题。比如，你如何剪辑你的内容？有没有你想说的话，但你必须马上自我审查？好吧，我要说的是绝对千真万确的一点：我们所有人都有这样一种方式——我知道你们在录完这个之后肯定在为我策划什么盛大的惊喜大餐，贝特曼。
Yeah, no. Back to Jason's questions. Like, what do you do to edit your stuff? Is there stuff you want to say? And then, but you have to edit yourself right away. Oh, Jason's questions. Like, what do you do to edit your stuff? Is there stuff you want to say, but you have to edit yourself right away? Well, here's the thing I will say that's absolutely true. There's a way all of us, I know you guys are planning some whatever big surprise meal for me after this is payment.
嗯，想象一下这一切都安排好了。我希望你们选的是加州比萨厨房（California Pizza Kitchen）。我们会在那儿狂吃海喝。但说真的，从事喜剧工作的人确实有一种习惯，我们会即兴发挥，谈论各种事情，滔滔不绝地开玩笑，其中一部分乐趣就在于说一些完全离谱的话。这很有趣，因为——我的意思是，
Um, imagine it's all been set up. And I hope you're like, California pizza kitchen. We'll be slamming them back, but no, in all seriousness, there is a way that people who work in comedy, we riff, and we talk about, and we get going on things, and some of the fun is saying things that would, that are totally outrageous. And it's funny because, I mean,
我遇到过最有道德、最有原则的人其实都在喜剧界工作，他们会就某个完全不道德、不原则的话题即兴说上一大堆，但这真的很搞笑，因为你了解他们，你知道他们只是在开玩笑，讽刺如果真去干那种事会有多荒谬。只是为了让你笑。
the most moral, ethical people I've met I've worked in comedy, and they'll go on a long riff about something completely immoral and unethical, but it's really funny because you know them and you know that they're doing a joke about how wrong that would be if they were to do that. Just to make you laugh.
只是为了逗我笑。而且那些房间——我的意思是，这就是我一直以来的感受。那必须是一个安全的空间。孕育喜剧的房间必须是一个安全的空间。孕育喜剧的房间必须是一个安全的空间，让每个人都感到舒适，可以完全、彻底地在政治上不正确。但问题是，你得确保当你走到外面世界的时候，你不是那样的。
Just to make me laugh. And the rooms, I mean, that's what I've always felt like. It has to be a safe space. A room where comedy's being invented has to be a safe space. A room where comedy's being invented has to be a safe space where everyone feels comfortable and to be completely, completely, politically incorrect. But the problem is that you have to make sure that when you go out in the world, you're not.
而且，你也不要跟那些真正持有这些我们深恶痛绝观点的人产生共鸣，那不是我们的目的。我们的目的是找到搞笑的点。而且，你知道，我总是想到——有些角色，比如《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）里的杰布（Gob），他是个相当讨人嫌的家伙。
And you and also like connecting with people who actually hold those views, which are a born to us, that's not the purpose of it. The purpose is to find funny things. And, you know, I always think about like, there are characters that, Joe from the rest of the development, he's a pretty despicable guy.
对。酷。但像他这样一个讨人嫌的家伙，我能理解他究竟有多离谱。没错。我并不是在赞同那种行为。我想说的是，他的为人处世荒谬得可笑。是的，我认为所有伟大经典喜剧的乐趣都在于，
Yeah. Cool. But like, he's a despicable guy, but I understood how completely off the rails he was. Right. And I'm not endorsing that kind of behavior. What I'm saying is, it's absurdly ridiculous how he is and thinks. Yes, and I think the fun in all the great classic comedy of all time
某人在某种情境下表现得完全不得体。所以，我——但这不是从扮演那个角色的演员本身是无知的角度出发，而是从他不宽容的角度出发。这就是你塑造杰布时的精妙之处。你总是显得有点笨，而不是不宽容。这就是你塑造杰布时的精妙之处。你总是显得有点笨，而不是……而不是那样。我不知道这有多少是刻意的、是靠天赋还是别的什么，
is someone being completely inappropriate in a situation. And so, I- But it's not a come from the actor playing that character as ignorant, as opposed to intolerant. And therein lies your skill with Job. You always looked a little dumb, as opposed to intolerant. And there, therein lies your skill with Job. You always looked a little dumb as opposed to... As opposed to that. I don't know how much it was intentional or talent or what,
但其中也有……看，看那边。看那个眼神。是的。他们做了一件事——我甚至都不知道这事——他们花了，我是说成百上千美元在后期剪辑上，在威尔的眼里加上了一抹智慧的光芒。
but there was also... Look, look right there. Look at that look right there. Yeah. They did a thing. I didn't even know this that they spent, I mean hundreds of thousands of dollars in editing, adding a light of intelligence to Will's eyes.
没错。就像一种存在感，仅仅是一种存在感，他们不得不逐帧处理，视频工作就是这样的。好吧，关键是要学会自嘲。所以这总是关于自我取笑。我就是个混蛋，我就是个白痴，
Right. Like a presence, just a presence, that they had, adding a light of intelligence to Will's eyes. Right. Like a presence, just a presence, that they had to go frame by frame, and that's how video works. Well, the key is to also try to make the joke on you. So it was always about making the joke. I'm the asshole, I'm the idiot,
而且这不是出于恶意。而且动机也是一个巨大的影响因素。你在这个时候说这话，动机是什么？是为了伤害某人吗？因为如果是那样，那就错了。如果动机是为了搞笑、为了逗大家开心，并且尽量不伤害别人，而是把事情轻松化，那么……
and it's not mean-spirited. And also, motive is a huge contributing factor, too. What are your motives when you're saying the thing? Is it too injure somebody? Because then that's wrong. If the motive is to be funny and to have a laugh and hopefully not injure somebody, but to make light, then...
你在你的节目里一直都很大方。我一直在延续你的整个喜剧风格。是不是，你从来没想过去装腔作势，你从来没想去当那个最酷的小孩？有些人……我当时非常努力地想装酷。我是喜剧界的一员。你从来没想去装腔作势，你从来没想去当那个最酷的小孩。有些人……我当时非常努力。我在努力。你在努力。
And you were always so generous with that on your show. I continued to do your whole brand of comedy. Is it, you're never trying to post you, you're never trying to be the cool kid. There are some... I was trying very hard. I of comedy. You're never trying to post you. You're never trying to be the cool kid. There are some folks. I was trying very hard. I was trying. You were trying.
我当时拼命想当最酷的小孩。这就是我装酷的样子。不，我……这就是为什么。但是……不，我人生很早就意识到，哦，我一点也不酷。我不是个优秀的运动员。
I was trying so hard to be the cool kid. This is me being the cool. No, I. That's what. That's why. But that. No, I realized very early in my life, like, oh, I'm not cool. I'm not a good athlete.
谢谢观众们立刻认清了这一点。我没有所有这些特质，但接着我盘点了我确实拥有的东西，并说，我要对此保持诚实，那就是……是的，而且从一开始就很清楚。就像，还记得他刚上节目时，按照设计，没有人知道你是谁。你是个镜头前的新人，但显然凭借你的背景、你的教育，
Thank you, audience, for recognizing that immediately. I'm not all these things, but then taking store of what I did have and saying, I'm going to be honest about that, which is. Yeah, and it was clear at the very start. Like, remember when he first came on, nobody, by design, nobody knew who you were. You were a newcomer to camera, but you were obviously with your background and your education
然后在这个领域工作。现在又做所有这些节目。我记得我看你的第一场开场独白时，我就想，哦，我明白了。因为你太有人情味了，太讨人喜欢了，太像我们了。我明白了。这就是你一干就是两年的原因。好吧，我们差点——我的意思是，在节目播出的两年里，我们不断地处于即将被砍掉的边缘。
and then working on this. And now on all stuff. I remember watching your very first monologue and I went, oh, I get it. Because you were so human and so winning and so us. I get it. That's why you did it for two years. Well, we almost got, I mean, it was two years on the air of constantly being this close to getting cancer.
对，我们每天都在担心你会接到电话。每天，不，说真的，我们确实——第一年挺过来之后，他们说我们要把你的合同缩短——这在我们这一行简直闻所未闻——我记得好像是一次签三个月。所以我们要每三个月给你续约一次。人们不知道这一点，因为大家只是，你知道的，这里的很多人，
Yeah, we were worried every day you were going to get a call. Every, no, seriously, we did, the first, after we got through a year and then they said we're breaking your contract down, which is completely unheard of in our business to, I think it was three months at a time. So we'll renew you three months at a time. And people don't know that because people just, you know, a lot of people here,
我现在遇到很多人，我说，好吧，我开始看你的节目时，你知道的，我15岁，现在我75岁了。所以他们根本不知道——太有趣了，人们的视角有多么不同。他们看着舞台上的每个人，然后就会想，好吧，你一直都在这个位置上，他们不明白，不，不，我们经历过——你知道的，在座的每个人，甚至可能任何对这个感兴趣或想尝试一下的人，你来到这里，看到你喜欢的人站在舞台上，或者其中的一些人，然后，
and I meet so many people now, I said, well, I started watching you, you know, when I was 15 and now I'm 75. And so they have no idea that it's so interesting how people have a different perspective. They look at everyone on this stage and they just think, well, you've always been at this place and they don't understand, no, no, we'll take, you know, we've all been everybody here who might even be interested in doing this or want to try it and you come here and you see the people that you like on a stage or some of them and
不，但你看到我们，然后你会想，哦，你们拥有——他们理所当然就该拥有这一切，但事实并非如此。比如，我非常——我觉得最重要的一点是，我时刻与这种感觉保持联系，而且我觉得这个行业里我喜欢的人——包括这里的每个人——我们真的非常清楚那种被人直接忽视的感觉是什么滋味。我们知道没有任何地位是什么滋味。我至今仍然跟那种感觉保持着连接。
then, no, but you see us and you think, oh, you have, they just got to be that and it's not the case. Like, I'm very, I think the thing, like it just happened to them. Yeah, I think I'm very much constantly in touch and I think the people that I like in this business, which includes everyone here, I think we're really in touch with the fact that we know what it's like to have people look right through us. We know what it's like to not have any of that status. And I'm still connected to that.
我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。你不得不经历所有那些事情，尤其是经历每三个月续签一次之类的折磨，你必须在全美观众面前经历这一切。所以你每天出场都要承受那种压力，还要应付那些说“我们对这种写作内容不太确定”的人，因为他们写信给我。
We'll be right back. And now back to the show. You had to go through all that stuff too, especially going through the three months at a time, whatever, you had to do it all in front of America. So you had all that stress every day showing up, and you had people saying, we're not sure of this component like writing stuff
你知道自己的脑袋悬在……你是如何在明知脑袋悬在……的情况下保持松弛并在节目中表现得搞笑的？对我来说，工作就是一切。所以对我而言，魔术般的秘诀在于：如果我们当时拍的——比方说我的节目有点像《周六夜现场》（Saturday Night Live）那种节目，明知脑袋悬在断头台上。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。
because they write me. How were you able to stay loose and be funny on the show knowing that your head was on the... What now is on the... For me is the work. So the magic for me was, if we had done, let's say my show had been kind of a Saturday night life show knowing that your head was on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor.
但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。但是地狱就在脚下。我早晨来上班，然后就会看到报纸上的这篇东西。字面意思就像是一个三页的通栏版面。
But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor.
列出柯南干脆死掉会有多好的75个理由。你知道吗？我的意思是，我真的没有夸大其词，因为我们当时做的事情在人们看来实在是太离谱了，
我看起来很怪，他的名字和头发是怎么回事。你看。而且你当时还有里希特一直在旁边拉着你的手。好吧，多么棒的拍档。那是另一个拍档。你不能夺走那个拍档。就是那一个。我不知道。
But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But hell is on the floor. But'd come out, I'd come to work in the morning and then say to just see this thing in the paper. And it's like literally like a three page spread. 75 reasons why it would be great if Conan just died. You know? I mean, I'm really not exaggerating that much because what we were doing just looked so wrong to people
你刚刚提到的那个名字在我家里是绝对不能提的。我想说，这节目是不是由普瑞卫健（Previgen）赞助的？请继续。不，先生。哦，哦，不过我能快速说一件事吗？那天我们必须把节目录完。当时发生了很糟糕的事情。
and I looked weird and what's this with his name and the hair. And you see. You also had Richter there holding your hand the whole time. Well, what a gap. That's the other gap. You can't take that gap. That's that one. I don't know.
但你刚才说的话绝对是千真万قات的。说到时间机器，如果我坐时光机回到过去，却没有安迪在身旁试图支撑我完成那个节目，我连三天都撑不下去。我是认真的。我是认真的。他是我们所知的最搞笑的家伙之一。
You just mentioned a name that's never mentioned in my house. I wanted to say, like, is this that been sponsored by Previgen? Go ahead. No, sir. Oh, oh, can I say one thing though, really quickly. Like, we had to do the show that day. And there were terrible things.
而且，他就坐在那儿。他就坐在我旁边。每当我状态不佳时，他总能说点什么。他就坐在那儿，就在我旁边，每当我状态不佳时，他总能说点什么。在早期的时候，他简直就是稳赚不赔的摇钱树。而且，我记得，他就像是一个庞大而温暖的存在，个子很高，就像——不，不，他就像是一个
But you said something that absolutely is true. Talk about a time machine. If I went back into a time machine and had to try and do that show without Andy, I wouldn't have lasted three days. I'm serious. I am serious. He's one of the funniest guys we all know.
庞大而温暖的存在。所以字面意义上，他能给人安慰。他能安慰我。比如，他是喜剧界里体格最强壮的人。他力气太大了。他有着疯狂的巨力。我是说，在体型上，我们以前经常开玩笑。我想我们有一次去洋基体育场打垒球，
But also, he was right there. He was right there by me next to me. And there were times when I didn't have it, and he would just say something. He was right there, he was right there, by me next to me, and there were times when I didn't have it, and he would just say something. And he was in the early days, he was just money in the bank. And also, I remember, he's just like this big warm presence, big guy, and like this with, no, no, he's this like
安迪好像随随便便就打出了一个垒球全垒打。每个人都惊呼：天哪！他却说：呃，走吧。我累了。一切就这么结束了。我在你的圣诞派对上看到他。每个人都惊呼：天哪！他却说：呃，走吧。我累了。我在你的圣诞派对上看到他端着满满一盘子——我和海因都拿了满满一盘。你会喜欢的。棒极了。
big warm presence. And so literally, he was comforting. He was comforting to me. Like, he's the physically strongest person in combat. He is so strong. He is so crazy strong. I mean, physically, like, we used to just laugh. I think we went to Yankee Stadium once to play softball,
而且，我确实想——我想起我在派对结束时发表的祝酒辞，当时我说这个房间里挤满了所有人，所有对我来说有意义的人。你确实说过。你还记得吗？哇。我怎么会不记得？
and I think Andy had a home run with his softball. And everyone was like, shit, he was like, eh, let's go. I'm tired of this. It was all over. I saw him at your Christmas party. And everyone was like, shit, he was like, eh, let's go. I'm tired of this. I saw him at your Christmas party with a plate full of heave and I both got a plate full of him. You would have loved it. It was great.
你是在消遣我吗？汤姆·汉克斯当时趴在我肩膀上哭呢。哦。但最初的计划里是要让安迪上节目吗？是吗？安迪最初是以编剧身份被雇用的，但我立刻就知道。我得把他弄上台。我觉得你们几个做点小研究会挺好的。
And, but I do want to, I do want to, remember the toast I gave at the party at the end when I said this room is filled with everyone, everyone that means something to me. You did. Remember that? Wow. Do I remember it?
听着，我本来想说的是你，阿门。让我们四个人一起坐地铁吧。你……但说到那些年，杰森，我们今天或者前几天还在聊，我们在聊……你当时在聊你在二十多岁时，已经有了自己的第一档节目，然后可能每隔几年拍一部试播集，经历那些岁月，每个人都觉得——
Are you getting me? Tom Hanks was crying on my shoulder. Oh. But was it originally the plan to have Andy on the show? Was it? Andy was hired as a writer, but I knew right away. I want to get him. I think it would be good if you guys did a little research.
哦，不，你过得……就像你说的，你很好。你是杰森，宝贝，你过得很好，每隔几年拍一部试播集，经历那些岁月，每个人都觉得，哦不，你过得——就像你说的。你很好。你是杰森，宝贝，你过得很好。你心想，天哪，我只是在努力融入这个世界。不，冒着显得过于真诚的风险，这对我来说是一件非常重要的事情，因为我希望人们能听到这个信息，因为我……我清晰地记得，
Listen, I know I was going to say that you, amen. Let's be on a subway, the four of us. Did you... But talking about those years, Jason, we were talking about it today or the other day, we were talking about... You were talking about those moments where you were in your 20s, you already had your first show, and then you were doing maybe a pilot every couple of years and going through those years and everybody sort of thinks,
看着那些拥有我现在这种地位的人，心想，那是他们，我永远不可能做到那样。而且对此深信不疑，就像太阳东升西落一样——虽然实际上地球才是这么运转的。看肖恩的脸，一脸茫然。但确实，你知道，我……其实，我刚才在想，我的朋友们，我的朋友戴夫·麦克劳克林和他的妻子
oh, no, you're doing... Like what you were saying, you're fine. You're Jason, baby, you're doing fine a pilot every couple of years and going through those years and everybody sort of thinks, oh no, you're doing like what you were saying. You're fine. You're Jason, baby, you're doing fine. You're like, man, I'm just trying to be the fucking world. No, that is a at the risk of being overly sincere. It's like something that's really important to me is that people hear this message because I am, I remember with great clarity, looking at people that whatever have the position
贝丝今晚也来到了现场，他们是我的老朋友。我以前跟贝丝睡过。你们俩站起来吧，贝丝。我以前……我不知道他们坐在哪儿，他们是我最老的朋友中的两个，我以前睡在他们公寓的地板上，在洛杉矶。我当时去试镜什么的，
that I have now and thinking, well that's them, but I could never get to do that. And being as sure of that as I am, like the sun comes up in the east and goes down on the west, which is actually how it works. Look at Sean's face, just be wilder. But yeah, you know, I, actually, I was just thinking, my friends, my friend Dave McLaughlin and his wife,
努力挣扎，快要饿肚子了，连房租都交不起，正是靠着这样的人的善良，我才撑了过来，我对此真的非常感激。我很喜欢，你知道，我喜欢聊这些事情，因为人们可能并不了解。你这是在试图打断戴夫和贝丝吗？抱歉。
Beth are here tonight, and they're good old friends of mine. And I used to sleep with Beth. Once you guys stand up, Beth. And I used to, I don't know where there are, and they're two of my oldest friends, and I used to sleep on their floor in their house, in their apartment, in LA. I'd go out for auditions or whatever,
不，因为几十年前我们刚开始一块儿混的时候，我会去你的公寓，而你隔壁的邻居——就住在同一层——就是布莱德利·库珀。对。而且那时候他真的很胖。对。我一直记得胖胖的布莱德利·库珀是怎样的。我一直……布莱德利……
and just trying and starving and couldn't pay the rent, and it was the kindness of people like that, and I just so appreciate it. I love that, you know, I love talking about this stuff, because people don't know, I think. Are you trying to cut off David Beth? Sorry.
他是那种需要把房子的一面墙拆掉才能运出去的人。他得被切开。他得被切碎送到医院去。他是个裁剪板。他是个裁剪板。肖恩来自伊利诺伊州，你不需要向他解释这个。对。但是。但是。击剑。
No, because when we first started hanging out decades ago, I would go over to your apartment, and your next-door neighbor in the apartment, next to you, like on the same thing, was Bradley Cooper. Yeah. And it was like... Yeah, but he was really fat then. Yeah. I always saw the fat Bradley Cooper was. I always... Bradley...
按州分类。这是个笑话。我们要去芝加哥了。到了那儿我就会承认的。不过说真的，布莱德利，还记得吗，布莱德利会过来然后说：“我永远不可能——”就像我第一次去金球奖颁奖典礼时一样。谢谢。
He was one of those people that they had to take a wall out of the house. He had to cut out. He had to cut him to the hospital. He was a cut out. He was a cut out. And Sean's from Illinois, you don't have to explain that to him. Yeah. But. But. Catsult.
呃，第一次。对，去金球奖。谢谢。呃，第一次。对。你赢过吗？没有。不，不，他只是——不，他只是弄到了一张票。
Stayed by state. It's a joke. We're going to Chicago. I'll admit to it when we get there. But yeah, Bradley, remember, Bradley would come over and be like, I'm never going to be like, I was just like the first time I went to the Golden Globes. Thanks.
被州政府阻止了。这太可笑了。我们要去芝加哥。等我们到了那里我就会承认的。但是，布拉德利，记住，布拉德利会过来然后说，我绝不会像……我当时就像第一次去金球奖那样。谢谢。
Uh, the. The first time. Yeah to the Golden Globes. Thanks. Uh, the- The first time. Yeah. Did you ever win? No. No, no, he just- No, he just got- He scored a ticket.
呃，第一次。对，去金球奖。谢谢。呃，第一次。对。你曾经赢过吗？没有。不，不，他只是——不，他只是弄到了一张票。
Oh, no. I was like, wow, I had my autograph book and my Sharpie. No, he went to the line. But to that point, the first time I went- I swear to God, this is what I thought. The first time I went- We were in the television tier, which is, you know. The first time I went, we were in the television tier, which is way in the back.
噢，不。我当时就想，哇，我带了签名册和记号笔。不，他走到队伍那去了。但说到这个，我第一次去——我向上帝发誓，我当时就是这么想的。我第一次去——我们在电视区，也就是你知道的。我第一次去的时候，我们在电视区，那是在很后面。
Movie people are in the front. And so I looked around and literally, there's Tom Cruise and Merle, she put all these people and I was like, how did I get, how did this happen? How did I get here? I know so many of my friends that could do my job in Winland Grace or whatever it was,
拍电影的人在前面。所以我环顾四周，真的，汤姆·克鲁斯和梅尔在那里，她把所有这些人安排在那，我就想，我是怎么到这的，这怎么发生的？我是怎么来这的？我知道我的很多朋友都能在温兰·格雷斯或诸如此类的地方做我的工作，
that could be in this position. And I looked around and just go, God, we're all lucky. That's just, yeah. Every single person here is lucky. Yeah, yeah. There's some more than you. We all do.
能在这个位置上。我环顾四周，然后就想，天哪，我们都很幸运。就是这样，对。这里的每一个人都很幸运。对，对。有些人比你更幸运。我们都有。
Do you? But I, you know, Sean. Sean? No, I mean, you really just fell. I mean, you were honestly lucky magazine posted, you know, a front cover, 50 covers in a row. But I think everybody, Lucky magazine poster, you know, front cover, 50 covers in a row. But I think everybody, but I think, I sure it takes a little bit of talent and hard work,
是吗？但我觉得，肖恩。肖恩？不，我是说，你真的是从天而降。我是说，你老实说，幸运杂志发了一期，你知道的，封面，连续50个封面。但我觉得每个人，幸运杂志海报，你知道的，封面，连续50个封面。但我觉得每个人，但我认为，我确信这需要一点点才华和努力，
but so many people have that. That's the other thing too, is, yeah, I get crazy, and it's not just in show business. I hate it, and finance, I hate it. We've all, you know, in a city like this in Boston, you'll see people that clearly have a ton of money they've made it in tech. They live out in some fancy suburb and they're hanging out at the four seasons.
但有太多人具备这些。这就是另一回事了，就是，是的，我常常抓狂，而且不仅仅是在娱乐圈。我讨厌这样，在金融界，我也讨厌这样。我们所有人，你知道的，在一个像波士顿这样的城市里，你会看到一些人，他们显然有很多钱，他们靠科技发家。他们住在某个豪华郊区，在四季酒店闲逛。
And they're just, sometimes there's this air they have of, I'm here because I deserve it. And I want to say, I don't know what your story is, but all of us are lucky. We're just lucky. And so that's something that gets like... Yeah. It's weird when...
他们有时会有一种气场，觉得自己能在这全凭应得。而我想说，我不知道你的故事是什么，但我们所有人都是幸运的。我们只是幸运而已。所以这就是那种让人觉得……是的。这很奇怪，当……
It's weird because actually, by the way, finance is the thing that's kind of taken over. There are probably a lot of finance people. And the only person we apologize to is Dandese. Dandese is the best. Is the best, but it's a, yeah, it's created a whole lot. No, when someone is, you know,
这很奇怪，因为事实上，顺便说一句，金融界反而是那种占据主导地位的领域。可能有很多金融界的人。而我们唯一道歉的人是丹迪丝。丹迪丝是最棒的。是最棒的，但这，是的，这造就了非常多。不，当有人，你知道的，
whatever, Betwell on crypto or something. And then they're kind of acting to me like, well, you know, some of us know what we're doing. And I think, fuck you, no. You know what I mean? But wait, don't you think that to all of what we're talking about, that you can, like, I'm not going back in my word, but it takes a little bit of luck,
不管怎样，在加密货币上押注或是别的什么。然后他们对我的态度有点像，嗯，你知道的，我们有些人知道自己在做什么。而我想，去你的，才不是。你知道我的意思吗？但等等，难道你不认为，就我们刚才谈论的一切而言，你可以，就像，我不会收回我的话，但这需要一点运气，
but you can manifest a little bit of it by creating goals and writing them down and achieving certain milestones as you go away, as you go along. I don't think there's a better analogy in the world than the one-armed bandit in. That's the way I always... I don't know if you've gambling's a problem for you, but you were coiled when I did that.
但你可以通过设定目标、把它们写下来，并在前进的过程中达成某些里程碑，来为自己吸引来一点运气。我觉得这世上没有比独臂强盗更好的比喻了。我一直都是这么……我不知道赌博对你来说是不是个问题，但当我那样做时，你吓得缩成了一团。
From this angle, it wasn't a real jackpot poll you were doing. You know when you got up, it's unreal. You are so on one track. But you know when you got a Las Vegas and those machines and you pull the lever, I'm sure. Oh, yeah. You don't need more than knobs. Well, there's the knobs, but then you're pulling that lever
从这个角度看，你刚才拉的并不是真正的头奖拉杆。你知道当你站起来的时候，那太不真实了。你真是太专一了。但你知道当你去拉斯维加斯，看到那些机器，然后你拉动那个把手，我确信。哦，是的。你不需要太多的旋钮。好吧，有那些旋钮，但接着你要去拉那个把手，
and you've got to really pull. And it breaks off, and you're like, and it breaks off. Yeah, it's the worst. But then the coins come shooting out. Sure. And then you just feel this sense of satisfaction and relief. But then your anus hurts, wait a minute. My point is this, we're going to clean this up.
而且你得狠狠地拉。然后它断了，你就想，然后它断了。是的，这太糟糕了。但接着硬币喷涌而出。当然。然后你就会感到一种满足感和解脱感。但接着你的肛门开始痛，等一下。我的意思是，我们要把这段处理干净。
Or they won't. They don't spend that kind of money. Well, let me ask you this. Wait, I got one thing to say was my, what I wanted to finish with, your point was that it is, yes, luck is important, luck is a crucial thing, and I wanna give it up to luck, but persistence, man. Yes, I think, I think actually persistence is,
或者他们才不理呢。他们才不会花那种冤枉钱。好吧，让我问你这个。等等，我有一件事要说，就是我的，我想最后说的一点，你的观点是，是的，运气很重要，运气是至关重要的东西，我想把功劳归于运气，但坚持，老兄。是的，我认为，我认为其实坚持就是，
there's just a tiny persistence group here. Oh. That's the name of their Bitcoin company now. I'll pay him in one bus. But like, my thing is just like, if you just keep going at it from different angles and keep pulling the lever, what there's also a dual.
这里刚好有一个微型的坚持小组。哦。那是他们现在比特币公司的名字。我要用一公交车送钱给他。但我的意思是，如果你只是从不同的角度不断努力，不断拉动把手，这里其实还有一个双重因素。
There's a plan and there's work ethic and studying hard at school and stuff. I know that you were educating here too. What were the school years like for you here? Were you a good student or were you a little health cat around town? Yeah, yeah. I, you know, you funny, you asked me the time machine question.
既有计划，又有职业道德，还有在学校努力学习之类的事情。我知道你以前也在这里接受过教育。你当年的学生时代在这里是怎么度过的？你是个好学生，还是城里的小野猫？是啊，是啊。我，你知道的，你很有趣，你问我时光倒流的问题。
And I'm not kidding for my, I mean, obviously, the time machine question is tricky because. It's a classic question. Yeah, it's a question of someone, it's a question someone has in their back pocket when they don't research. Uh. Uh.
我没有开玩笑，我的意思是，很显然，时光倒流的问题很棘手，因为。这是一个经典的问题。是的，这是一个当别人不做功课时会藏在背后的问题。呃。呃。
Thank you. Oh. Time is seen, so do my art. Public card out. I don't know. I was just telling you, my views on Roe v. Wade. Time machine! Time machine desert island discs.
谢谢。哦。时光倒流，所以做我的艺术。公开卡片出局。我不知道。我刚才正跟你谈我对罗诉韦德案的看法。时光倒流！时光倒流荒岛唱片。
Oh. Oh, brother didn't know. I had to talk Jason. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, I did go off. I'm gonna talk Jason. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, I would go back and have people not know where I went to college because I do think early in my career especially people had preconceived notions of that. And so sometimes people would act like, oh, this show you're gonna do is gonna be some like smart number.
哦。哦，兄弟不知道。我得和杰森谈谈。是啊，是啊，是啊。不，我确实跑题了。我要和杰森谈谈。是啊，是啊，是啊。不，我会回到过去，不让别人知道我去了哪所大学，因为我确实认为，尤其是在我职业生涯的早期，人们对这一点有先入为主的观念。所以有时人们会表现得好像，哦，你要做的这个节目会是什么高深莫测的东西。
No, I like a masturbating bear. I like the silliest things in the world. And I kind of wish that people didn't know where I went to school. I was very, I worked really hard to go there. I was a grind. And I worked even all those years. I was writing comedy in college and performing it. I was still a really hard worker. What do you do you think now? So we get sort of this is on top of what we were talking about. How does it feel? Is it when you come back to Boston specifically after those years of grinding in high school and going to college here and now you're in front of this crowd
不，我喜欢自慰的熊。我喜欢世界上最愚蠢的东西。我真希望人们不知道我是在哪里上学的。我很，我为了去那里付出了非常努力的汗水。我曾经是个书呆子。那些年我一直在努力。我在大学里写喜剧并进行表演。我依然是一个非常努力工作的人。你觉得现在怎么样？所以我们把这个建立在我们刚才讨论的基础上。感觉如何？当你回到波士顿，特别是在经历了高中时期的苦读、在这里上大学的那些年之后，现在你站在这样一群人面前，他们显然出于某种原因而倾慕于你。这是为什么，这令人满足，还是说这很离奇？你对此有何感触？你能承认这一点吗？然后说，嘿，这挺好的。我在这方面越来越擅长了。很长一段时间里，我都没有，人们会写一些好评，或者会有好事发生。
who clearly adores you for some reason. Why is that, is that satisfying, is that bizarre? Does that register for you? Can you acknowledge that? Go like, hey, that's good. I'm getting better at it. For a long time, I didn't, people would write nice things, or nice things would happen.
而我会想，嗯哼。然后我就会把它推开。但你以前也走过这些同样的街道，我想象过，你和你的父母一起来到城里，做各种事情，也许还会来到这家剧院看演出什么的。我觉得那时候这里还没有。当时王氏剧院就在这吗？
And I go like, mm-hmm. And I would just push it aside. But you used to go down these same streets, you'd come into town, I imagine, with your folks and do stuff and maybe come to this very theater and see shows and whatever. I don't think this was here. It was the Wang even here.
我觉得王氏剧院是建好了的。是的，不，王氏剧院一直都在这。王氏剧院在这里已经三百年了。哦。我想。当第一批，不，王氏剧院一直都在这。王氏剧院在这里已经三百年了。哦。我想当第一批定居者到达时，王氏剧院就在这了。这是他们建造的第一栋建筑。他们当时说，这里的音响效果还行。
I think the Wang was built. Yeah, no, the Wang's been here. The Wang's been here for 300 years. Oh. I think. When the first, no, the Wang's been here. The Wang's been here for 300 years. Oh. I think when the first settlers arrived, the Wang theater was here. This is the first thing they built. And they're like, the acoustics are OK.
你可以做个播客。但我的意思是，你四处走过。不，不，我非常清楚地意识到我一直极其幸运。我经常想的一件事是，我的祖父，我母亲那边的祖父母，在马萨诸塞州伍斯特长大，还有，是的。
You could have a podcast. But I mean, you walked around this. No, no, I very much in touch with the fact that I've been extremely fortunate. The thing I think about all the time is that my grandfather, my grandparents on my mother's side, grew up in Worcester, Massachusetts, and a, yeah.
我的祖父在伍斯特市中心指挥交通。那是他的职业，他有薪水。我喜欢那部电影。他们太棒了。他每周能拿到55美元的薪水。每当娱乐圈里发生什么事，有人对我说，好吧，如果你只做了一年脱口秀，所以这就是我们要付给你的，
And my grandfather directed traffic in downtown Worcester. That was his career and he got paid. I love that movie. He were amazing. He got paid $55 a week. And whenever anything happens in show business where someone tells me, well, if you just did a year of talk shows, and so this is how much we're gonna,
我对这些狗屁感到非常谦卑。这太难以置信了，我会想起我的祖父，我在他生前拒绝承认他。哇。顺便说一句，毫无理由。我只是非常，你知道的。一个简短的，哈佛小故事。杰森荣获了……
I'm very humbled by shit. This is unbelievable, and I think about my grandfather, who I refused to acknowledge in his lifetime. Wow. By the way, for no reason at all. I just was very, you know. Just a quick, Harvard little story. Jason was honored with the...
他正在放……是的。是的。他接受了。他接受了是因为他以为……他最初以为他们提供给他的是美味的布丁。但是杰森，你为什么不和大家分享一下今天发表的那篇精彩文章呢？
He's putting... Yes. Yeah. And he accepted it. He accepted it because he thought... He thought they were offering him a tasty pudding at first. But Jay, why don't you share with everybody about the wonderful article that came out today?
哦，那篇文章。今天有一篇美丽绝伦的文章。在每日新闻上，你知道，这有点像新闻业的巅峰，他们说我收到了这个，奥扎克的明星得到了，得到了，不，得到了，得到了，得到了那个该死的布丁，
Oh, the article. Beautiful, beautiful article today. And in the daily news, you know, it's sort of like the zenith of journalism, they said that I received this, that Ozark's star got the, gets, no, gets the, gets the, gets the hazy putting it away,
然后在正文里，奥扎克的帕特里克·贝特曼获得了美国精神病患者奖。在写这篇文章时，仅仅做最少量的资料搜集到底有多难？我能告诉你们我最喜欢的事吗，我会收到一封信。这至少每年发生一次。一封来自相当知名的机构的信，上面说，你是我们最喜欢的艺人。
and then in the body of the thing, Ozark's Patrick Bateman received the American Psycho. How tough is that to just the smallest amount of research when you're writing this article? Can I tell you my favorite thing is I will get a letter. This has happened to me at least once a year. A letter from a pretty well known organization that's saying, you're our favorite entertainer.
巴波巴波巴波，请问你能来我们备受尊敬的机构演讲吗？这将意义重大，我们一直怀着急切的心情关注着你的职业生涯，这将会是空前盛大的事情。我对你佩服得五体投地。是的，是的，完全正确。但我得说，这封信还会继续写下去，
Bo-bo-bo-bo-bo-bo, could you please come and speak at our esteemed institution? It would mean so much and we followed your career with Bated Brass and it's gonna be the biggest thing ever. And I floored at you that. Yeah, yeah, exactly. But I'll say the letter will go on and on
然后它会说，亲爱的柯南，紧接着姓氏就被拼得一塌糊涂。我会想，你根本，你他妈的一点也不在乎我。你知道吗，就像，你连范本都懒得改。这就要说到我们之前的电子邮件对话了。这就像，他妈的，你难道就不能在里面加个逗号，
and it will say, dear Conan, and then the last name is terribly misspelled. And I'll think, you didn't, you don't fucking care about me at all. You know, like, you're even kicked from the sample. This is getting back to our email conversation. It's like, motherfucker, can you just put a comma in there
或者类似于，或者，或者，他们知道自己在做什么，他们就是想要你这种反应。对吧。平心而论，当我走到这里看到索耶时，我就想，帕特里克，你知道的，我很高兴看到帕特里克·贝特曼。好吧，我告诉你，我告诉你，我们一直很高兴见到你。
or something like, or, or, they knew what they were doing and they wanted this reaction from you. Right. In fairness, when I walked out here in Sawyer, I was like, Patrick, you know, I was excited to see Patrick Bateman. Well, I tell you, I tell you, we've been excited to see you.
是的。嘿，对于一个必须离开的人来说，这是个绝佳的过渡。是的，我们要进广告了。好吧，不，我的意思是，你知道。不，那是，我必须说，这是，我将重复我的座右铭。这不是工作。这是，对我们所有宝贵的两年来说，这是一段漫长的时间。我们许多人都一直怀念聚在一起、拥有
Yes. Hey, that's a great transition for a guy who has to get out. Yeah, we're going to commercial. Well, no, I mean, you know. No, that's, I have to say, this is, I will repeat my mantra. This is not work. This is, and it's been a long two years for all of us. And a lot of us have been missing being together and having
观众的时光。所以，说真的，是的，当我接到，当我接到，当威尔说，你想不想出来参加波士顿的“聪明笨蛋”时？我当时就想，这就像，我想参与，所以谢谢你们。哦，我太喜欢了。说真的。
an audience. And so, seriously, yeah, and when I got, when I got, when Will said, would you wanna come out and be on a smart list in Boston? And I was, I was just like, this is like, I want to contest, so thank you guys. Oh, I love it. Seriously.
不，真的，这感觉真好。真的非常好。顺便说一句，我也对此深表同感。能做这一切，能开启这次巡演，来到波士顿，见到你们大家，和一个我们都深爱的、如此搞笑、而且一直都是最棒的好哥们一起做节目，对我们来说简直是太刺激了。
No, really, this is nice. It's really nice. This is, by the way, I echo that we do, too. This is such a thrill for us to do this, to do this tour, to come here to Boston, to see you guys, to do with such a good buddy who we all love and you are so hilarious and you've always been the best.
这些年来，你对我们所有人都总是那么亲切。我们会为此努力的。我们会为此努力的。我们会为此努力的。让我来做圣诞节的中间人吧。我只在派对上负责停车。好的，太棒了。我只想留在会场里。
You've always been so kind to all of us over the years. We're gonna work on that. We're gonna work on that. We're gonna work on that. And let me broker the Christmas. I'll just park cars at the party. Okay, great. I just want to be on the grounds.
你想留在会场里。是的，好吧。并在这次派对上邀请一些大牌明星，一些顶级A咖。你可能会有点晕眩。顺便说一句，他不是在开玩笑。是的，不。这里全都是A咖。
You want to be on the grounds. Yeah, okay. And get some pretty heavy hitters, some big A-listers at this party. And you might get a little giddy. By the way, he's not kidding. Yeah, no. It is filled with A-listers.
好吧，你要怎么办？听着。哦，不。我得走了。我要去见汤姆·布雷迪。你们大家，这有多棒？大犯规。嘿，大家。我爱你们。太有趣了。
Well, what are you gonna do? Listen. Oh, no. I gotta go. I'm meeting Tom Brady. You guys, how great is it? Big foul. Hey, guys. I love you. That's the fun.
你们最近都怎么样？快进来。再见，老兄。太棒了。哇。太棒了。我真不知道他个子这么矮。我知道。全是嘴唇。
How you all been? Get in here. Bye, buddy. That was great. Wow. That was great. I had no idea how short he is. I know. Those are lips.
全都是嘴唇。我们应该再出来承认一下那些嘴唇。那你怎么没问他？我是说，你没有问你那100个问题。根本没有。我不想问。我们在聊天呢。你有周六夜现场的经历，关于辛普森一家的事，深夜秀。
It's all lips. We should come back out here and admit to the lips. So what didn't you ask him? I mean, you didn't go to your 100 questions. There's no one. I didn't want to. We were having a conversation. You got SNL, the stuff about Simpsons, Late Night.
你本来都知道这些。你的名字被他拼错了。对。你根本不需要他。你是个出色的采访者。哦！哦！我爱你。
You didn't know all that. You have his name, Miss Pelt. Yeah. You didn't even need him. You're a great interviewer. Oh! Oh! I love you.
这真是个傻……那威尔呢，哈？肖恩。史蒂夫，史蒂夫呢？不，但是，那，那，那，柯南绝对是我在过去节目中接待过的最最喜欢的嘉宾之一。当然，但我很好奇，因为我不知道这一点，我想知道他是不是，
That's a silly... How about Will though, huh? Sean. Steve, what about Steve? No, but that, that, that, that Conan is one of my favorite, favorite guests we've had on the, on the past. Absolutely, but I wonder like, I, because I don't know this, I wonder if he is like the,
他是主持时间最长的脱口秀主持人吗？也就是说他的年限是最多的吗？我敢说约翰尼·卡森主持的时间更长。是的。但28年。28年。是的，是的，是的，算上各种不同的节目。我的意思是，一定是的，是的，算上所有的节目。
is he the longest hosting talk show host? Like did he have the most years? I bet your Johnny Carson went longer. Yeah. But 28 years. 28 years. Yeah, yeah, yeah, with various shows. I mean, it has to be, yeah, with all the shows.
是的，太疯狂了。我不知道，但是当我还年轻的时候，哦，开始了。不，只占几分钟。这与其说是别的，不如说是独白。哦，也是。不，但我记得看柯南的深夜秀，看那些小品，
Yeah, that's crazy. I don't know, but you got but when I was a young actor, oh, here we go. No, it's just gonna be a few minutes. It's more of a monologue than anything. Oh, so is. No, but I remember watching Conan on late night and just watching all those sketches
看他的，必须看他的独白。必须看那些小品。总是如此。我不在乎嘉宾是谁。我只想看那些小品，作为一个年轻的演员，这太令人鼓舞了。是的，我最喜欢他的一点是，我上大学时就开始看了，我就想，哦，那家伙的幽默感
and watching his had to watch his monologue. Had to watch the sketches. Always. I didn't care who the guest was. I just wanted to see those sketches, and as a young actor, it was so inspiring. Yes, and when I loved about him too, like I started watching when I was in college, and I was like, oh, that guy has the same sense of humor
跟我一样，有点古怪。这不像，我现在在做一段生硬的独白，然后我要和一个嘉宾聊天。这完全不同。太不一样了。而且现在依然不同。我喜欢那个女孩。别告诉我你只是在做。谢谢。那是什么？这是我的脱口秀，依然不同。我喜欢那个女孩。难道你不是在做，那是什么？
as me, it's like a little wacky. And it's not like, I'm doing a stilted monologue now, and I'm gonna talk to a guest. It was different. It was so different. And it's still different. I love that girl. Don't tell me you're just doing. Thanks. What was that? This is my talk show, it's still different. I love that girl. Don't you just do what was that?
什么？这是我的脱口秀。这是我的脱口秀。一个不知道自己在做什么的主持人。太不可思议了。谢谢。你看着我，而我唯一在做的事就是绞尽脑汁想一句俏皮话。我在努力思考。
What? This is my talk show. This is my talk show. Host who doesn't know how he's doing. Incredible. Thank you. You're looking at me and all I'm doing is trying to think up a buy. I'm trying to think about it.
哦，是的。也许有什么关于他有着双……好吧，别大声说出来。我觉得……好吧，如果你只是重复我们刚才采访过的那位嘉宾的名字，里面可能有什么线索吧。哦，不，不。哦，再见！
Oh, yeah. Maybe something about him being bicostle with... Well, don't do it out loud. I think... Well, if you just repeat the name and the guest that we just had, there's something in there, maybe. Oh, no, no. Oh, bye!
再见！再见，谢谢你，波士顿！欢呼和掌声 谢谢。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Bye! Goodbye, thank you, Boston! CHEERING AND APPLAUSE Thank you. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。《聪明笨蛋》由贝内特·巴尔贝科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·昂朱夫100%有机手工打造。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barberco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Unjurf. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。《Smartless》由贝内特·巴伯科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·昂哲夫百分之百有机手工制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。